as we're preparing to uh uh publish this
show we got breaking news FDX founder
Sam bankman freed has been found guilty
on all charges including multiple counts
of fraud conspiracy and money laundering
it's kind of funny he's a a big Democrat
donor and there's also talk about wasn't
he the guy who was like offering Trump
hypothetically billions of dollars not
to run for president was that him
hypothetically yeah hypoth it was that
was that was that was what was going on
it was never confirmed but people were
saying hey might have offered like how
much would you like if to not run for
president I think there was a bunch of
people that were close to him that
actually said that he was he was
offering that or something okay so this
is breaking news right now uh the other
story we were planning on leading off
with is that a judge in in uh uh I'm
sorry in Connecticut overturned a
Democrat primary after video emerged of
ballot stuffing and the interesting
thing about this is that it's not a
victory the general election is still
happening and it is presumed that the
candidate who should not be the
candidate on the ballot is still going
to win so this this is a really really
interesting story we'll talk about that
plus the uh uh the invasion in in Gaza
is it's interesting um we had on the
show someone talk about the strategy
that Israel would take in Gaza if they
were to invade and that would be to
bifurcate the Gaza Strip I think it
might have been Max Blumenthal but this
is exactly what Israel is doing right
now so we'll talk about that we got a
bunch of other stories the uh the house
passed a bill for Israel funding but no
Ukraine funding and they're saying it's
going to be dead in the Senate now
because of that but I think it's
hilarious that Ukraine's basically been
cut off poor zinsky before we get
started my friends head over to cast
brew.com if you want the best cop of
coffee you've ever had go to cast brew
and pick up our rise with Roberto Jr
Halloween special limited edition blend
now now check this out this there's only
a few thousand of these and there will
never be any more after this this is the
plan this is our Halloween edition where
you got a chicken foot emerging like a
zombie from the earth pick it up while
you can of course everyone's favorite is
rise with Roberto Jr but I'm hearing now
that people really do like stand your
grounds which is our medium roast when
you buy Cas Brew Coffee yeah Ser has the
best when you buy casw coffee you are
actually helping fund our coffee house
project we are going to be building a
bunch of cafes hopefully soon one's
currently in the works all of the
profits that are that we're getting from
Casp basically go into the staff and the
equipment and building this coffee shop
so if you like the idea of a hangout
where you can hang out with people in
the real world support us at casper.com
but also go to
timcast.net we're going to have one of
those up for you tonight at 10: p.m.
where you as members can call into the
show and talk to us and our guest it's
going to be a lot of fun so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends joining
us tonight to talk about this and a
whole lot more is Joshua Smith hey
thanks so much for having me again Tim I
appreciate it who are you what are you
doing uh I am currently a candidate for
president for the libertarian party uh I
am the host of break the cycle podcast
on YouTube every Thursday evening at
7:30 uh Central Time and uh I am a
father of six uh was passed National
Committee for the libertarian party and
uh anti-war activist since 2008 I'm also
a uh anti-communist and
counterrevolutionary in case Phil's not
here tonight very very original Oh wait
but what kind of musician are you a
failed musician very failed musician
right on well thanks for hang out bless
we got Hannah Clair hanging out hey I'm
Hannah Clair brimo I'm a writer for
timcast.net
coming at you hard subscribe to me on
YouTube hi uh I'm surge.com uh good to
have you back again thanks yeah miss sgy
your hair looks great thanks bro
appreciate it
anyways here's here's here's the big
breaking news as of 7:51 p.m. CNBC Sam
bankman Fred found guilty on all seven
criminal fraud counts the month-long
trial of Sam bankman freed wrapped on
Thursday uh it say a jury has found him
guilty on all seven criminal uh criminal
counts the former FTX CEO faces a
maximum of 115 years in prison bangman
fre the 31-year-old son 31-year-old son
of two Stanford at legal Scholars and
graduate of MIT has pleaded had pleaded
not guilty to charges including wire
fraud Securities fraud etc etc etc we
get all that stuff the trial ended blah
blah blah we get it okay all this this
is just like the the bits and Bobs we
don't care about who was this guy what
was he doing he was a big Democrat donor
yeah and there's a lot of speculation
that he was basically using these
schemes to help fund Democrat
politicians yeah he donated to over 300
uh political campaigns and directly to
the DNC there's another big conspiracy
theory that the money that was going
through Ukraine was coming back through
him to the DNC that was the big that was
the big conspiracy theory I don't know
if it's been proven yet or not but it
wouldn't surprise me at all at all yeah
there I can't remember what that was
there was something a man it's been so
long like we we're seriously uh getting
ready for the show and like oh look at
this big you know vote vote voter uh
cheating story and then boom breaking
news bankman freed is is found guilty on
all counts but but it is a fact
that he was this big Democrat donor the
money he was making what was he like he
wasn't that well off and then he started
FTX and all of a sudden he skyrocketed
in net worth and capital yeah billions
and then he immediately starts funding a
bunch of democrat politicians now I'll
just I'll be nice I shouldn't be but
I'll be nice that doesn't implicate any
of these politicians but it certainly
shows the people at least some of the
most powerful people here it is who are
funding these politicians are criminals
who are using dirty methods of funding
these politicians and then I've got
questions about how act blue operates
James O'Keefe with the O OMG Media Group
did a big story about uh and this is
coming from them that money from China
was flowing through act
blue I got a lot of questions about what
what these people are up to you that
wouldn't surprise me either I gladly
trade SBF for for uh Ross alri today to
the federal prison we should get Ross
out there he he created e-commerce
website that did he though uh did he
actually create it yeah uh I mean maybe
for people who aren't familiar the uh
he's he's the dread pirate Roberts well
they yeah they say that but he did I
mean he was the creator of of silk road
but he they don't know if he was there
was several dread pirate robers um but
they don't know if he was the one that
had to do with the the murder For Hire
stuff they just brought it up in court
dragged them through the mud and then
dropped all those charges and then put
him in prison for two and a half life
sentences right this is the Silk Road
this is where people were buying and
trading a bunch of stuff whether it was
legal or not and uh the username was
dread pirate Roberts so one of them yeah
one of them argument was he he makes
this or someone made it and they pass it
off to someone else sure and they just
share this name you guys have seen The
Princess Bride oh yeah the truth is I am
not the dread pirate robets yes exactly
the real dread pirate rits died years
ago it was really genius I mean if you
think about it the way they they ran
that but but he said in in in prison for
two and a half life sentences for an
e-commerce website and nothing more
really I mean that's basically what it
was Tucker Carlson meant to went to meet
Julian Assange see see that I did see
that I have not w i mean the episode
hasn't come out yet but right yeah I saw
that he went to meet with him but I
don't know if I don't know if they're
filming anything I don't know if he's
able to film in prison God I hope they
let him yeah that'd be interesting but
either way I'm curious if y'all think
this is a blip this guy getting caught
getting busted or I think this may be a
component that we've seen of the
faltering of the uh Neo uh uh the neoc
corporate liberal neocon neol
establishment it's it's it schemes are
failing I mean some people like to say
since Epstein got taken down it started
to look like it's unraveling perhaps I
don't know maybe this was their attempt
at creating some kind of alternate
creepy International funding scheme no
idea but when you see stories like this
it certainly is a grain of sand at least
in the Heap of all of these like
surreptitious plans and like shady Deals
they used to do are getting exposed
every day I mean you look at the Biden
stuff they're not saying $40,000 went to
Joe or something like that you like more
money is being found Trac to him you I
kind of feel good about it I don't know
what do you think I I definitely think
that this is just one of many I don't
think this is the only instance like
this and you know these people
absolutely hate us and and want us sick
and tired and dead mostly um I me and
these are the people that are funding
them I think it's probably going to be
if the mainstream media can they'll spin
it to be like this is why you should
fear crypto this is what the issue is
Never Trust crypto don't look for
alternative currency people who push
alternative currencies or you know
scamming you or whatever else they'll
try to avoid the fact that he was
ultimately in the camp of the DNC and
that's what I am concerned about they're
only going to break they're only going
to break the altcoins because the
Bitcoin Community is way too strong yeah
but wait he was doing is running an
exchange the cryptos themselves are
legit some of them are extremely I
believe that but I think the average
American is not so well versed in in
crypto to understand the the differences
so we got to get them more well versed
think that's great but you are now
racing the mainstream media who's trying
to protect the DNC right they're GNA say
no no it's not that he was influ taking
money from Democrats or trying to
influence anything political it's this
technology that you're scared of and I
say that as a full-on technophobe right
if if you are afraid of crypto you don't
really understand the difference between
an exchange and the coins and all
currency or whatever else you're going
to say this guy scammed a lot of people
and the mainstream media embc says that
I can't trust them and that's what they
want you to believe they don't want you
to make the political connection well
then we need to be ready with the
counternarrative that that's fine just
bitcoin's much safer they can't stop
crypto they can't stop crypto because
too many people are just sitting there
waiting for their get rich quick scheme
because they don't quite understand how
it works but uh I think you know when I
when I talk to regular people who don't
get it the only thing the average person
I like when I talk to regular people I
typically hear first and foremost do you
think it's going to go up because
everybody remembers when it jumps to
like 20K and people got rich overnight
everybody remembers when it jumped to
60k and people got rich overnight and
everybody is just waiting for that
opportunity to jump on the next wave and
then it goes back down I mean it went to
like 60 it went down to what like 17
yeah but zoom out it's never actually
gone down I mean we've it's had a
pullback kaboom Spike Spike Spike and
well it's because the way Bitcoin
operates I think uh we're due for a
having soon aren't we I'm not sure I
heard about I heard that last week about
that I just don't track the schedule
next April or something something like
that and and that uh uh I'm not going to
pretend to know what that means but a
lot of people are like oh boy get ready
because basically what this means is is
the super simple not I I don't run a
Bitcoin company but the super simple
version is the amount of energy to
produce uh uh the amount of energy
required per per Bitcoin is going to
double yeah block rewards are cut in
half basically and that means if it
costs let's just let's just do dry units
100 units of energy to create one
Bitcoin after it's cut in half it's
going to be 200 units of energy for one
Bitcoin meaning your costs will double
and you're going to have to charge more
no one's going to want to sell like for
this reason that's basically forcing the
prices to go up not to mention it's it
it it it's uh the attrition of Bitcoin
itself yeah specifically in April 2024
the block rewards will decrease from
6.25 to 3.125 did you what was this Max
Kaiser offered Alex Jones 10,000
Bitcoins last week or whatever did you
see the TW the Twitter of him going
we're not selling he's like screaming on
stage we're not selling wait wait wait
he so the story is Max offered Alex
Jones 10 th000 Bitcoins 300 something
million dollars by today's standard and
Alex like didn't care and like lost it
or something said whatever and then Max
told him I'll give you another 10,000 if
you can answer five Bitcoin questions
and Alex couldn't do it and apparently
they were like not complicated questions
but they questions like basically if
you're in Bitcoin you knew right and uh
he offered him $300 million well that's
not even enough to cover half of his
fines unfortunately you no a third yeah
that's the funny thing like if he
actually gave him the crypto it' be gone
in two seconds
by the way I did a show with Chase Geer
this morning Chase Infowars that's what
made me think about it early this this
morning check it out um also when you're
wondering is crypto going to go up you
also got to ask yourself is the US
dollar going to go down yeah because
it's they're inversely proportionate we
really need to be we need need to get
out of this like is it going to go up
and down like narrative and start we got
we got to figure out a way to like uh
pass this this dream of mass adoption
because it's going to be so important if
we ever look if if the the central
banking system ever fails and it's not
about when it's about if I believe that
it will eventually no you mean talk
about if it's when yeah that's yeah
that's what I meant yeah that's what I
meant I I mixed that up but yeah
absolutely when when it happens um you
know if you're on something that already
has a framework worked out you're going
to feel a lot less blood than the normal
person who has no other Investments I
could see like Amazon Jeff Bezos just
being like now you can pay with Bitcoin
I could see something like that
happening that's I mean that's that's a
part of mass adoption and the more
people that accept Bitcoin the the the
closer we get to that mass adoption the
more that people start buying Bitcoin
the more Bitcoin stabilizes and you stop
seeing these these these big backs and
stuff like that and people got to start
thinking about it as as what it is it's
a it's a you know unit of of money it's
your you know when you can start making
purchases of with it it's it's Salvador
yeah and and people in Salvador are
doing great things I mean the economy
has been pretty well off since they've
done that get me though if you look at
the entire crypto Market all of them
according to coinmarketcap.com the
entire Market's 1.3 trillion dollar
that's like nothing compared to the US
us could print that up and buy it all
it's just a matter of finding it but
like doesn't seem stable to me that it's
that little and it could be that moved
around by the global governments why do
you disagree I just I don't think that
they will I don't I think that they want
they want full control over the
blockchain right and so that's why
they're going to push cbdcs because
those they'll have the opportunity to
shut down your money on the spot you
know what I mean they could take if you
said the wrong thing on the internet
they could shut down your money boom
they want that kind of control they
don't have that kind of control of
Bitcoin but they could easily get it I I
disagree I just don't think they I don't
think I don't think that they I don't
think they care enough about it to do
that I think that they want to find a
way to tax it but there's also other
there's other ways to have Anonymous
Bitcoin exchange as well you know level
two and and uh lightning Network and
stuff like that too it's becoming more
Anonymous it's not it's not becoming
more like government friendly as we as
time goes on so the issue is once there
is look it's it's really this simple New
York City says if you accept Bitcoin
from our band list then we are going to
find you $10,000 a day and we already
saw what happened with masks they will
all immediately bend the knee so you so
you can't stop someone from having
Bitcoin sure but government can stop you
from being able to use it but Miami
actually is encouraging and and what
they and what they'll do is if they
really want to ban you they'll they they
they will issue a mandate to all
terminals at stores these addresses are
out the ban list and they'll argue these
are terrorists and criminals and if you
facilitate through these so what will
happen then is smaller level businesses
will say can we get a can we get
something that will instantly add these
addresses to our terminals cuz we can't
track all this then a company will be
like we're terminal safe make sure
you're not funding terrorism upload our
government approved uh uh you know ban
list and you're only Banning people who
are terrorists and then they got right
well that's also why we need like
government officials that are going to
like ban chainalysis and and like you
know uh Bitcoin trackers and stuff that
the federal government use now get there
the federal government will absolutely
but the decentralized the decentralized
revolution is going to eventually find a
way around it whether whether it's a new
kind of web development or something
it's going to come along that will
continue I feel like people make this
mistake with a lot of things politics
and Technology are not as relevant as
culture and morals and so when you look
at everything in this country the people
are complaining about I'm like yeah our
culture has completely decayed our our
morals are gone and you've got people
who are willing to lie Che and steal to
take whatever they want because they
don't care of course not completely
though what you mean I'm watching the I
want to save a little bit this this for
later because I was watching some of the
trial the Minnesota uh Trump hearing on
the 14th Amendment and we know what's
going to happen with this the judges
don't care what's right they care about
winning for their ideology yeah they're
partisan now I and so right I'm like
nothing your technology doesn't matter
okay the guy with unless there a civil
war New York City will simply say in a
mandate if you accept from these Bitcoin
addresses we will find you
$110,000 and every business will drop to
their knees and beg steady government
please make it easy for us to not
accidentally give facilitate these
transactions but if you did that you
could send the person could send their
Bitcoin from that address to a different
address and then and all they have to do
is say any any Bitcoin that transfers
from this address to the next is now non
persona non grata and then you're going
to be like dude are you on the list I
don't don't don't screw my Bitcoin bro I
can't trade with
you be like shoting yourself in the foot
if if if an economy did that to
themselves they'd be like they'd be in
the dust trying to push for stuff like
that currently legit I
guarantee by today's standards with AI
and machine learning they can easily
create algorithms tracking active
blockchain transactions they know who
you are they know what you're buying and
even if you create a new wallet they
will know because they're spying on your
phone when they're going to know if the
addresses are being operated from the
same device where it's being where the
transactions are they're going to know
it's you yeah but you can get around
that too you can get around the device
stuff you can use to and all kinds of
you are not going to be able to beat an
AI you will you are not going to walk
into a McDonald's and be like my burner
phone's going to beat the AI it's go bam
and you're going to go what why isn't it
working I just bought a burner phone and
put money because they track they're
tracking you put your phone in the
freezer put under running water ditch it
there there's cameras everywhere I mean
you look at these Amazon stores my my my
point is it is possible that we we find
a way to overcome this my I'm I'm just
saying well they're actively working on
ways to overcome it now I mean that's
you lightning network was part of that
so there needs to be a cultural shift in
what we are willing to accept and
tolerate right now because humans
absolutely Americans especially tolerate
being spied on and we we are walking we
are zombie walking into social credit
scores sure I don't disagree with you at
all I I I absolutely 100% think that
America has headed towards social credit
I think they're going to Market it as
something that's good for you right it's
conv I think about that there's this
girl on Instagram chip girl and she's
got like whatever in her hand and she
can pay for stuff and this is her whole
social media influencer you know I'm
sure she talks about other things but
the fact that she is chipped is a big
deal and it becomes glamorous right
she's also constantly showing off her
luxury goods it's going to be part of
the cbdcs though is what it's going to
it's it's all going to come down
chipping is not not going to be a thing
at least for now and the reason is
rejection so uh when when you put a chip
under your skin they can reject it yeah
people can reject it and so that's not
foolproof some people will be fine some
people will not be fine uh it'll be part
of your cbdc wallet what I mean is mean
they they'll market soci credit store as
like well it's so convenient for you
look it's easier it's faster to do
things I think people won't see it
coming because it'll be misrepresented
to them for what it is right sure sure
my my my theory is that what happens is
is we're going to have a financial
crisis we're going to have a banking
collapse maybe only uh 20% of the US
Banks collapse that's a huge percentage
it is it's a huge percent but but it's
not 100 it's not 30 it's it's going be
at least 20 for sure 20% doubt and then
what happens let's say you're uh give me
a give me a b it's not too big but big
enough I mean I don't know it's tough
right I mean uh let's do we're we're out
here we got what do we got uh PNC PNC
sure PNC I see I see them in PA a little
bit smaller but they're still kind of
big a bank like that fails and then what
happens is everybody who's got this
account says my business the payroll for
my employees right look my business we
had 500,000 in the account we I got to
pay my weight my my server staff I got
to buy new pizza rolls what am I going
to do my bank account's gone federal
government immediately snaps their
fingers within a couple couple days they
say we are bailing out the American
people this is not about big business
this bank went under we're mad but we
are going to ensure all of the money for
all of these people 100% not up to
250,000 like uh FDIC says we're going to
ensure all of it rest assured small
business you will pay your employees
tomorrow simply download cbdc app at
Google play.com and download fed dollar
oh God and they're going to say gross in
order to get access to your account
input your social security number your
account number and your information into
the into cbdc app and you will get the
US dollar equivalent of fedcoin I'll
tell you right now if if if cbdcs had
already been a thing during the coid
crisis the pass the passports would have
been a thing let me slow down for
everybody Central Bank digital currency
yes correct cuz I know a lot of people
are like cbdc we're going too fast
you're in the jargon now Central Bank
digital currency the idea is Bitcoin is
decentralized and everything I explained
about how they'll try to take it over is
what they'll have to to try to do if the
federal uh government or the FED can
launch a central bank digital currency
like fedcoin they will have instant
access and control to everything and
then you get social credit scores but
they don't need to tell you they're
rolling out social credit scores they
will just exist yeah you'll get a
notification on your app and it will be
like we're concerned about some activity
on your on on your external profiles
they've already introduced the idea of
off-platform behavior all your
Healthcare stuff's going to be on there
too I mean that's oh yeah that's the
scary part I you'll have no more privacy
it just sounds like setting up for a
black market if they try and do stuff
like that people get pissed off they
don't want a pissed off population right
now but but black market doesn't matter
okay like you know Sheamus makes this
point about abortion when the left says
yeah but if you ban abortion there will
be Black Market abortions and he was
right and most of it will still be
illegal and that will stop most of it
great there's always going to be illegal
activity that's that's that right
so the the the the concerning thing I
suppose you're going to have this app
and we've already seen on Twitter and
Facebook and YouTube you can be banned
for what they call off-platform Behavior
right yep the cbdc app is going to have
terms and conditions and it's going to
say you agree that if you use this app
you can't do these things and the people
who are in a crisis whose bank accounts
have been you know have collapsed and
are gone they're going to sign anything
yeah oh what do you do they you rased
your business overnight oh no and it's
no one's fault the bank just failed do
you remember PayPal trying to do that
trying to find people for off platform
yes they find them and this is these are
all instead they just ban people who do
stuff they don't like they they they
they have this provision on PayPal it's
$2500 for like some kind of hate speech
provision they will fine you they'll
fine you for saying naughty words not
just not just like not take your money I
mean they will fine you they will give
you a fine if you have no money in your
PayPal you will be negative $2500 here
here so the crisis scenario is scary but
how about the tax benefit scenario where
they say we're rolling out a a a a
Federal Banking App they're going to say
something like these predatory uh
lending companies and banks are are
charging an arm and a leg why is it that
if you're poor the bank charges you
money you look at your bank account
you've only got 25 bucks the next day
you look at negative 15 they charged you
they they charged you for that because
you didn't have enough in your account
now you're negative now you owe them
money but if you're rich they pay you
that is unfair the post office will be
opening Holdings accounts for yes right
for all Americans download the post
office app it is a no fee Bank bank
account for you the American people with
interest rates no more overdraft charges
now you've got a federal government
banking system you download the app you
agree to their terms of service don't
say naughty words and they're monitoring
every single transaction you make every
single thing you buy let's let's let's
jump to the story from uh uh we'll get
jump into the news here as we're talking
about you know s bankman freed and uh
political corruption this is a big story
that's been that broke yesterday
Connecticut judge overturns results of
mayoral primary just days before
election why because they got evidence
on camera of a Democrat ballot stuffing
Wednesday's ruling is the latest twist
in an election centering on allegations
of absentee ballot abuse the election
captured widespread public attention
after a video surfaced online appearing
to show a supporter of incumbent mayor
Joe ganam stuffing stacks of papers into
an absentee ballot Dropbox I I wonder if
uh I think we have the uh there's a
video of it yeah there's a video so uh
this is an image these are the people
that govern you by the way in these news
outlets are they really do not want to
play the video you got to get the video
on Twitter I'll pull it up in a second
but uh here's what's interesting they're
not stopping the election no this guy
won the Primary they've now overturned
the primary doesn't matter he's still on
the ballots the general election is
about to happen it's presumed he's going
to win and they they speculate that when
he does this will end any challenge to
the primary well with election heing
like that how could you lose you know
it's just crazy I suppose the answer is
you can't exactly that's that's the game
boys that's what they do they want sorry
I just I just think about like every
time they're like this doesn't happen
this is something the Republicans made
up because there's they're just crazy
they're sad they lost or whatever else
and then there's this video of this
woman doing exactly the thing that
people fear and believe happens in their
elections well my favorite narrative is
like everyone when Joe Biden got elected
and everyone's like oh it was totally
above board that stuff never happens and
I'm like you're the same people that
were doing this when Trump won when Bush
won you were talking everyone was
talking about the voting machines when
Bush won I mean you've been doing this
for for decades and now all of a sudden
they're above board entirely there's no
election interference all right I found
the video it's not even easy to find
this video here you go here's the video
that uh allegedly is of a Democrat
ballot stuffing who is
she um I we'll pull up the name from the
article in a second there and they have
several videos of her doing it by the
way it's not right right this is a
minute and 53 seconds long yeah so uh
let's jump oh they said that she came
back several times yep drop number two
and how many ballot boxes are they well
how many B boxes name they got they got
her name in here too I
think here she goes again this is uh
Wanda Wanda that's all we get I
guess I think we should say her full
name so people know so here's the here's
the crazy thing let me see if it's h in
this article is it
uh uh they don't have it no they don't
have her name in article uh here here's
here's the thing people need to
understand when Donald Trump and his
supporters were suing over stories like
this it is a lie that they were all
thrown out right of the uh major I think
the majority of the cases were were uh
thrown out on standing arguing the
individuals who filed the suits did not
have a they were not affected in this
case therefore they had no nothing to do
with the with the contents of the law
which is insane any voter anyone any
citizen in this country has has standing
in my opinion of the the cases I think
there were 30 that were ruled on the
merits 22 were found to be uh in favor
of trump however because in each of
these individual cases either the number
of ballots or some other issues uh for
inance one example is the number of
ballots did not equal a large enough
number to have changed the election it
was ruled moot right it doesn't matter
if we win for you anyway because you
still lost the election but it doesn't
mean there was no election nearing going
on there was certainly for B frud
question to over the election the courts
courts look yes you found 300 B in fraud
but there's a 7,000 margin here so
what's the point of this because these
courts do not take action on those it
keeps happening and then what happens
when you get 15 judges in one state and
you get 15 instances where it's 100
votes or I'll say a th and the margin
7,000 and now there's 15,000 fraudulent
bouts confirmed by courts but because
each individual judge looks at one small
individual individual case they dismiss
all of them right I don't I don't think
that is the the case for the most part
when it came to Trump my point is on a
granular granular level we can see
directly local elections are easily
easily flipped with one person doing
something like this and this is Democrat
V democ this is a Democratic Primary in
a blue State and they are still stuffing
boxes it's the only reason we're hearing
about it I know but that's what's
interesting this is the thing that when
it happens when when conservatives or
Republicans or third party candidates
say hey we were in some ways uh there
was fraud in our elections it's
typically left leaning candidates and
left leaning supporters who are like no
it never happens but it happens in their
own primaries how can they argue against
this I promise you it's not the third
parties doing it so I just want everyone
to know everyone everyone knows the
Libertarians are the ones secretly
rigging the election for we the ones
rling demat yeah absolutely we're
rigging it for the Democrats well and
the funny thing is is like the Democrats
should be just as worried about not just
because it's happening in their own
primary but because maybe Republicans in
small towns are doing it too you know
everybody should be worried about this
there's no no chance that this is
isolated event we know that and like
everyone should wake up and be worried
about these things one of my favorite
things in elections every four years
you'll get conservatives being like if
these Libertarians just voted for the
Republican party then we would have won
and I'm like my guy the Libertarians
don't like you yeah we don't like you at
all Libertarians are like if Republicans
just voted for us we would just win yeah
if you guys just stop voting for this
like deeply entrenched corrupt party
that you'd have a better chance of
changing the NYPD by yourself than you
would of getting like you know 700
people together and trying to change the
Republican party at a federal level at
least the Republicans a state and local
can do stuff like my governor and Iowa
has been great on a lot of things you
know but like this this you know there's
a lot of little small like positions
that the Libertarians can win and do win
we win 200 election cycle or something
like that do you feel like the
libertarian party focuses not enough on
the this small I've heard this argued
before that it often is like trying to
be at the top of the ticket when really
they should focus on capturing key
positions in our biggest problems is re
is resources I mean the national the
national party runs on like $1.7 million
a year um they can't help a a
presidential candidate almost at all
presidential candidates tax with keeping
us ballot access um raising all their
own funds all that stuff but we do run a
lot of down ballot candidates and I
think in 2022 with the misus caucus
takeover that became the bigger Focus
was the localization nullification of
you know federal law at the state and
local level and that's the really
important thing that the any like
presidential candidate for the
libertarian party should be doing this
media tour talking about how hey you can
take over your local guns you can take
over your school board you know all
these terrible policies that the schools
are doing you have the opportunity to
run if you got a Tuesday and a Wednesday
free every week you can go run for
Schoolboard you know it's it's not that
hard and you should because even in West
Virginia woke people are masquerading As
Trump supporters to get elected and then
introduce weird crackpot adult content
to kids yeah you should be running you
should be running if you have if you
have two week nights a free a month or
something I mean you could really run
for some of these small positions in
small towns and change everything so
where do you see the most Libertarian
activity in the US like I always think
New Hampshire I've I've interviewed a
couple Libertarians from North Carolina
in the past I can tell you the most
registered uh libertarian voters per
capita is Nebraska um but that's because
New Hampshire like when they did the
free state project they all registered
as Republicans and Democrats to take
over those positions as Republicans and
Democrats so um that's changing now in
no sure of course a lot more people are
joining the libertarian party there but
you know the in Nebraska they they just
have they're pretty libertarian State I
don't know we're we're in Iowa we're not
far behind them in Iowa as well but
we're uh libertarian part is a national
major political party in Iowa because of
our gubernatorial candidate who ran in
the last election he got a high enough
percentage made us we don't have to
worry about ballot access or anything
like that anymore but now we need a
presidential candidate that can step up
and do those things so that we don't
have to worry about it anymore you need
like 5% right it's there's there's some
speculation it might be a little bit
higher closer to 12 12% but um it every
State's different is the thing right
like every state has a different
threshold so there's like half the state
over half the states if we were to get
5% we'd never have to worry about ballot
access again at least not for another
four years so um it's an important it's
an important thing you know if you're in
a swing state and you're not worried
about your candidate losing there throw
throw a vote at us let us let us get
seven s to 12% you have to register as a
Libertarian in some states some states
are all states are different they all
have different election laws so it just
really depends yeah so what do you
expect going into this cycle I mean
where are you expecting to spend the
most time it's going to be it's going to
be an interesting cycle with RFK running
for sure but there's a chance you know
everyone's really worried about RFK but
there's a chance he doesn't get on the
ballot right he's running independent
it's going to cost him millions and
millions and millions of dollars to get
on the ballot in all 50 states he may
get on in a few States but I don't think
he's going to be on the ballot in every
state so it's going to it's not it's not
as big of a deal as some people are
making it out to be but um we're
focusing on 50 states I mean that's
that's the thing we want as many votes
in the popular vote as possible all the
way across the country so that we can
hit like at least a 5% or maybe we do
well enough in the media and we get that
15% in some of the big polls and we can
get on the debate stage because that's
really what we want if we can look
Donald Trump and Joe Biden in the eyes
and tell them how bad their policies are
hurting the middle class in America like
that's what we want to do you know
because that's what really what this is
all about so that's that's the focus for
me at least my campaign all 50 states no
Foreign Wars no Foreign Wars uh you know
try to dismantle the Federal Reserve as
much as possible of course take down as
many of these federal agencies as we
Poss possibly can um and and VI is right
about this I mean we we can't as a
president you don't have the power to go
out there and abolish all these federal
agencies but you can lay off 70% of the
workforce or just relocate them to
unalaska well you can you can get rid of
70% then take the last 30% and relocate
them to maintenance departments and mail
rooms at little precincts around the
country and then you know maybe we get
the FBI small enough to where they stop
focusing on trying to infiltrate
Catholic groups and go after uh you know
uh meican drug soccer moms at school
board meetings to call them you tell you
got I got a plan to revitalize this
country and it's easy how many how many
federal uh uh uh employees are there do
you know oh a lot I don't know it's it's
one of the biggest jobs programs in the
world I know that now I got an idea all
right we'll start with the FBI how many
FBI agents do we got I don't know I'll
look it up to yeah let's pull up let's
pull those numbers you got the uh uh FBI
ATF you want to abish the IRS right well
I mean as much as possible Right the
first one the first one no no don't
worry I got a plan uh how many how many
do we got and a clair I Haven found it
yet I'll tell you in a second enough to
infiltrate Catholic groups no well look
look look let's they're saying they
imply uh 35,000 people but I feel like a
guy FBI yeah it's probably more than
here's what you do you don't got to fire
them all you don't got to fire them what
you do is you take
1,000 you you you get 35 units of a
thousand and you relocate them into
rural nowhere places like Central Alaska
I'll tell you why because then Federal
those federal dollars will go towards
creating cities where it will require
the development of Industry right sure
you'll create you not only are you going
to force people to live in areas you're
basically colonizing our own country so
you know we got a bunch of stuff in
Alaska we should go up there and and and
re Source our own resources stop working
on China you've never been you've never
been to Alaska in the winter have you I
don't care this is great they can quit
if they want there's a reason why people
don't live there Tim but before you fire
them you say we're going to give you you
know like four more years of employment
but it's going to be in Alaska sure have
a nice day and then when they're there
there's you're going to have to build
housing you're going to have to build
infrastructure then what happens is
these people they need to eat right so
someone's going to open a store
someone's going to open a restaurant
then when you have workers there you
have the opportunity to colonize our own
country instead of seeing our cities die
how about this I was looking at this
City renovo Pennsylvania and I was like
this is a really cool town but it's
dying it was a railway town and uh like
I there's like a thousand people live
there just send send send 500 FBI agents
you got to live there now you're
stationed here and then all of a sudden
you're revitalizing that town and giving
these people their jobs back you see
what you see what I'm saying and then
after four years you fire him there's uh
there's do we have to give him the full
four years to can we do like May one
here's my point here's my point you're
basically using them as a means to help
middle Americans Revitalize their towns
and create some kind of like
revitalization for these areas that need
industry and then you get rid of them
we're simply not going to have the
funding for that put me 2.87 million
Federal civilian employees in 2022 wow 2
how how many 2.8 they're like soft ggs
giant well then and you got to add to
that okay so that's a huge jobs program
right probably one of the biggest jobs
programs in the world but then you got
to add to that all the government
contracts for people who get government
contracts that's the very largest
employer in the history of the world
maybe ever right so I mean it's really
wild to think about I mean there is a
reason that as the federal government
grew you saw expansion in Maryland and
Northern Virginia right because other
businesses came there so to Tim's point
if we were to say you know what was it
uh the department of the Interior they
moved it to Colorado under Trump and
then under Biden they're like no no
we're going back to DC we don't want to
be here but theoretically if you were to
station these Federal Outpost somewhere
else ventually shut it down or whatever
else you're making these contractors who
want these contracts or want anything
else go where they are they're not just
centralizing DC it's so crazy to think
about that these these government
contracts cuz like basically if you're
making a lot of money in America right
now it's probably through a government
contract this is the the most the
biggest employer in the world and they
put that EO Joe Joe uh Joe Biden put the
EO back that said that all these uh
government contracts have to have a de
Dei program you guys know about that no
so like if you're if you have a
government contract with federal
government your company has to have a
Dei Department y ABS 100% Trump had
ended the EO and Biden brought it right
back and so like when we talk about Dei
and ESG and stuff in America right now
like that's where it's all stemming from
is from the federal government they're
literally pushing this on every Let's uh
let's jump to this story we got this on
post millennial Tucker Carlson says RFK
Jr will pull votes from Trump not Biden
there's no person who's thinking I'm G
to vote for either Joe Biden or Bobby
Kennedy and Tucker is wrong yeah he's
definitely wrong he's absolutely wrong
on this I think this is more of a
passive statement he made speaking on a
podcast because it does not seem like he
actually looked at the data or had real
conversations I think Ian's a good
example cuz Ian talked about how his mom
is a big fan of the kennedies yeah yeah
she loved uh Bobby and she would never
vote for Trump no I don't think so so
this maybe if she met him this is a
perhaps this is a very simple piece of
math it's probability let's say uh your
mom's probability of voting for Biden is
80% and voting for Kennedy is 20% and
voting for Trump is
0% that's the kind of math where if you
have enough of those people it can only
pull from from Joe Biden it can never
pull from Trum I remember when uh Robert
Kennedy announced he was going to Robert
Kenny Jr announced he was going to run
for president within like 3 days they
slandered him or smeared him with antia
on the news and I called my mother like
right away and I was like hey watch out
for this antia crap they're going to
start calling him now that he announced
and she's like yeah but I don't know I
just don't know how I feel about I'm
like dude two years ago she was saying
how much she loves Robert Kenny Jr and
it's like the news started to get to her
right away so there might be something
there where they're they're tainting
people's opinion of the guy he's going
to pull he's going to pull from both of
the the big parties I believe 100 yeah
but it's going to be it's going to be 65
from Democrats and 30 from Republicans
if if that I I I just got to say man
I've not met a single person who said
who who who who will say publicly I'm
voting for Trump who has now been like
well I'm going to vote for arc's dead
well oh you go ahead I was say there was
um a poll done in New Hampshire a couple
weeks ago maybe a month and it was
asking people you know who you're voting
for whatever else we saw that Chris
Chrissy was intensely unpopular there
but uh when they asked what RFK he did
have really high support from
Republicans but none of the Republicans
planed to vote for him and none of them
plan to vote for them vote for him if
their first choice candidate left right
it doesn't change the fact they like him
Republicans are excited that he's in the
race but ultimately his support is still
among Democrats and we saw that when he
announced his independent bit it still
leaned left in the language I believe
that if R RFK and this is a wild
conspiracy theory that's not going to
come true this theoretical but if RFK
was to drop entirely and start trying to
run as Donald Trump's vice president I
think that that he could get that I
believe that talk about last night too
RFK Jr is reparations proun control Eco
fascism I don't yeah I mean he's big
he's big time we've talked about Trump
RFK in the past but this was only in the
context of the the coid response as a
means of helping correct the image of
Trump's failures on it but now rfk's
pivoted in recently much more heavily
especially with reparations and is on
his Ann uh at his announcement he said
it's indigenous people's day it was
Columbus Day but right right he he's
he's jumped off government backed bonds
to save the housing market I mean this
guy's just like he's a run-of-the-mill
progressive that's good on healthare and
the Deep State I
meat give him a c he might be like in
charge of the EPA or something right if
he really wanted to be like no I know
you guys like him ex exciting but I
don't see him I saw being floated around
attorney general too yeah yeah maybe I
mean I think it's just not a close
enough Bond I'm sure there's probably
some sort of respect there for you know
whatever cordial reason but I don't
think that there is a close enough uh
camaraderie between the two of them and
also I think Trump's be really careful
about who he picks for his VP because
look at what happened with Mike Pence
right I mean he picked someone who he
thought was neutral and that ultimately
ended very badly he's only going to be a
four-year president if he's elected and
that's uh he needs someone who's really
going to back him the the fly was a
better BP than Mike Pence for sure so
yeah yeah pant was such did you guys see
did you guys see the poll on Twitter
that was Chris Christie or a hogy
sandwich and the hogy sandwich beat him
like 69 I'm hungar it I'm hungry I'll
take the H there was like there was like
30,000 votes on there and and the hogy
beat him like almost 70% Christy be a
good interview cuz Christy is the most
PA you might end up seeing him sit
across from you so be care whatever you
say say it to his face he keeps doing
this Donald Duck thing oh yeah dude it
is the cringest thing cuz he's so
excited when he says it on the debate
stage he's like Donald Duck and then
everyone's like you're an idiot yeah he
wants to be Donald Trump so bad like he
really does he wants to be able to
insult people like that he's just not
quick enough cuz he's to overweight man
if he was thin healthy he would have a
way better chance a lot more people like
healthy he wouldn't be funnier if Donald
if Donald Trump was in a one-on-one
debate with Christie and Christy was
like this guy Donald keeps ducking all
these questions he's Donald Duck Trump
would go you're fat and that's it and
everyone would go
roaring that's all it would take that's
it that's all it would take absolutely
100% that's all he would say cuz Trump
has no he has no filter at all zero
breathing in the microphone exact
yep he'd say something like that he he
make that face and
go Lord over here can hear him breathing
and then everyone just busts out
laughing and he's done Donald Duck is
not funny it's not clever it's stupid
and Trump would just do the most crass
bottom of the barrel yeah and you're fat
yeah and then everyone would start
roaring with laughter like all would
take I I have seen Trump rallies I have
seen that man speak he's a standup
comedian the shut up silly woman thing
is all over the Internet still to this
day that you'd be in jail one
shut up silly woman yeah that's all over
that's all over the Internet still
Hillary did you say that to Hillary no
he he was a rally he was a story yeah it
was a
rally yeah I I I if you've not seen a
rally this is what I hear from people
they're like I wasn't a big Trump fan
and I decided to go to his rally and I'm
a trump fan like because the guy you're
going to a comedy routine man he's doing
what John Stewart basically did back in
the day he's up there and he's saying he
I'll give you the formula it's like you
got problem I know about problem I'm
going to insult the people who make
problem and everyone starts cheering for
it I kind of like and he does it well
watching old Trump videos cuz you his
personality like you see who he was when
he was young you see who he is now I
think it's a lot you get a better like
more well-rounded idea of who he is
super cool Shane Gillis can literally go
up on stage and impersonate Donald Trump
verbatim and the whole crowd dies
laughing and he's just saying what Trump
said that's it exactly verba and and
Shane Gils like one of the best standup
comedians in world right now yeah so I I
I tell you like the key to getting your
your friends and family to go over the
line on like I don't know about Trump
they complain about whatever just come
with me and see what he says and they're
going to leave feeling great well I
don't want you to vote for Trump though
so oh I know you don't but I'm saying
for people like when when you actually
see the guy it's the entertainment value
that he's making you have a good time
this is like a kind of this is a little
bit of an off off tangent metaphor but
like the whole Mean Tweets thing they're
like instead of a guy with Mean Tweets
I'd rather have a warmonger right is
kind of like on YouTube we can talk
about death and destruction and and that
but we can't say the FW I mean you can
obviously say it but like what the FW is
like the Mean Tweets of the internet
censorship like yo bro I'm not sure what
f word you're talking about there's a
lot of funny ones Fanny oh okay uh sorry
Australians anyway that we say the f
word on on break the cycle all the time
so I love you were saying before we
start the show that Charisma is one of
the deciding factors in it's very
important you can't be a presidential
candidate without Comm it's a giant
popularity
most important thing Trump like how how
you Define wit right like what's what's
like the colloquial it's just a quick
it's a quick brain I mean it was really
what it is quick enough it's quick
enough to equp with people I mean back
and you don't need to be super
intelligent and articulate you need only
be quick with it so like the point I was
making with Chris Chrissy being like
Donald Duck and then Trump going I can
hear fat so over here breathing in the
microphone and it's it's not the
smartest thing in the world but it it's
it's it's it's he knows he knows how and
when to say things exactly it's it's a
timing thing it's a timing isue I think
it's intelligence it requires like at
least 16 intelligence the thing the
thing the thing about on a maximum of
what the thing about politics about 18
is maximum human potential and then you
become superum above that sorry interrup
no I no it's fine I was interrupting you
I was literally interrupting you no I I
so the the thing is is like in politics
you only have to have like a minor
understanding of most issues and then be
charismatic enough to talk about those
issues because the the vast majority of
the American public has no idea what
these issues mean anyways at
allence this is the Aleppo moment in a
nutshell yeah when uh Gary Johnson was
asked about a leppo and he goes and what
is a leppo it's just Charisma one right
and then everyone all anyone saw was
this guy doesn't know anything about
what he's about what's going on he could
have he could have said he could have he
could have made up nonsense yeah he
could have said well you know the
economic standard with Aleppo is is is
is troubling to me to be completely
honest but we're going to we're going to
get a policy in place in Washington it's
going to solve that problem they go wait
what but the average person would be
like oh
okay because they just needed to have an
answer the other part about that is it's
a city in Syria by way it makes him seem
like he's not surrounded by people who
are saying these are the most important
issues because we all know a president
gets you know an intense number of
briefs and theoretically they're
surrounded by experts on each I'll tell
you the biggest the biggest problem with
Libertarians literally this is the
biggest problem is we are all extremely
well read at libertarian philosophy
we've read Murray rothbart and F hyek
and misus and all these great economists
and Austrian econom economists and
philosophers and just everything you
could possibly imagine Henry Haslett and
blah blah blah blah blah and then you
want to go out and you want to lecture
this to people and no one cares
literally no one cares they want to hear
about how you're going to make their
cast prices go down that's what I care
about I just wanted to clarify too
because I I wasn't sure on that it's not
the capital is it not the capital
capital Damascus that's right I thought
it was Damascus but you said that I was
like let me double check before iasc one
thing that Libertarians a problem they
have too I think is that they're not
like obsessed with global Military like
you got to be in order to be a great
commander-in-chief of our military you
got to understand like how are we going
to dominate and annihilate everything on
Earth so we don't have to no but we're
not going to do that that's we're not
but you have to know how so that you
don't so you know how not to we would'
be much we' be a much safer Nation if
our you know two-third of our military
wasn't station around the world because
if the president doesn't understand it
if the president's not a military expert
then someone else is going to run the
military the thing is they just have to
know enough about it and have the the
the reality is whoever is the president
may be really well-versed on a couple
issues right they might have let's say
five that they know backwards forwards
they know everything about but
realistically they're going to need a
staff that is able to yeah that that
relies on expertise and is able to brief
them quickly and so that's why you know
when Gary Johnson gets the Aleppo
question wrong it means he did not have
anyone around him to say this is a
current issue that you should know about
and that's one of the problems going
forward I mean this was a criticism
people had of trump when he was in the
White House was that the people who
surrounded himself with did not look out
for his best interest and maybe were not
guiding him in the right direction it's
unrealistic to expect a president to
know absolutely everything yeah but a
lot of that was his fault too because he
he was going to drain the swamp and then
he surrounded himself with the swamp I'm
not saying it wasn't But ultimately this
is a problem that could be true for a
Libertarian president it could be true
for a Democrat president it is not
actually the person on stage who knows
everything as the people they're
surrounding themselves with yeah
president does have generals but the
commander must know military Doctrine or
at least rapidly learn it upon but under
that in that logic we would only want
people who had served in the military to
be presidents which could be true in
some eras right but theoretically right
now I mean as far as I know Joe Biden
didn't serve in the military maybe he'll
tell us something different uh Trump
went to military boarding school right
but he didn't actually serve in the
military so theoretically both of these
people have
the yeah when was the last time we had a
military commander like a mil
ex-military guy or woman guy George Bush
was it George Bush was he in the
military the first the dad you mean HW
weren't they both in the mil they were
both in milary but W was wasn't his
story that he didn't go to Vietnam or
something something like that but he was
in the military I mean was it how far
back are we going a did Clinton serve in
the military not that I know of no
Clinton was we have to work backwards
Reagan was a movie star J Kennedy
Kennedy was in the Navy I think in
Vietnam and he received I was he like he
wasn't purple heart but he received like
some very serious award for saving
people yeah literally he like saved a
bunch of dudes off a what a sinking ship
or some crazy story that would be a
great story Tosh served in the Navy
during World War II George Bush George
George H W bush Navy wow well let's jump
to the story from the AP ladies and
gentlemen you may not be aware Donald
Trump is facing uh eligibility questions
for the 2024 presidential race in
Colorado and in Minnesota and in
Michigan and probably a bunch of other
states but we've got updates on the
Minnesota hearing the AP says Minnesota
justices appear skeptical that states
should decide Trump's eligibility for
the ballot I watched some of this live
and I got to say this these
hearings what we are watching right now
with the question of Donald Trump's
eligibility is an attempt by democrats
to run a stake through the heart of the
United States and the arguments made in
Minnesota really spell this out I'll
give it to you very simply I believe it
was Trump's lawyers who was arguing this
who was arguing this states do not have
the Constitutional authority to
determine eligibility they state
legislatur are given wide um a wide
capability or or wide um responsibility
and governance over elections in their
states but not eligibility which is a
federal question meaning if someone's
eligibility is challenged it must be in
a federal court Donald Trump was
questioned over this in his impeachment
hearings and was found not to have
engaged in Insurrection therefore the
question is done they're now taking it
to the states to argue he did the
argument was was was actually really
simple if someone's 27 years old there's
no question of fact you're not eligible
to run nobody has an issue with it
Insurrection is different Insurrection
has to be determined but the
Constitution at the federal level
determines the eligibility for a federal
elected official states don't get to
decide who is eligible or not if it
becomes that de if Democrats succeed in
even a single state set a precedent then
the precedent will be there will never
be a us election again now hold on we'll
have North Korea style elections where
you'll have one person on the ballot why
elections will become instead of hey
let's go get as many votes as possible
it's time to go vote that's what we do
now but don't get me like don't get me
wrong I know it's all bot harvesting now
it's it's it's months of work knocking
on doors and the goal is get a bigger
number than the opponent by any means
necessary if this goes through and
Democrats succeed future elections will
be like this um okay uh uh sir it is one
year before the general which means it's
eligibility season we better get those
arguments ready for court to determine
whether or not you're eligible to be in
this state a president will then have to
win eligibility hearings in all 50
states and if they don't their name will
not appear on the ballot a dummy
candidate will and it will be like a
North Korean election in every state you
will then get every blue State saying
Joe Biden and you know uh Bobby Bobby
doe the Republican no one's ever heard
of him doesn't matter it's Joe Biden
versus Bobby and everyone's like who's
that well that means that there's not
going to be a popular vote for Trump
then the red States will do the same
thing well Joe Biden's not eligible
actually it's probably the Republicans
will do nothing and it'll only be the
blue states that are cutting off all the
Republicans but theoretically then red
States say nope we had we had
eligibility hearings a year ago and we
found Joe Biden to be ineligible for
these reasons therefore the belt will
only be Donald Trump and the Democrat
will be RFK Jr and then Trump wins
easily and then you're going to get red
leaning swing States and blue leaning
swing States and that's going to be the
battle where instead of an election
appointed
officials hired corporate lawyers will
argue to judges who the president should
be I don't know about you but it sounds
like a great segue to National divorce
myself you know I'm a fan I uh this
ain't happening no this isn't going to
happen and if and if this if this goes
through no no this could happen I don't
think I don't think these judges are
hyperarch in Colorado is a donor to a
pack specifically to remove Republicans
who supported Trump on January 6 our our
whole entire justice system has become
hyper partis I'm not under what's going
to stop this Colorado judge who already
donated money to stop Republicans over
January 6 what's going to stop that
judge from being like I don't care what
you said Trump your name's off going
stop the Supreme Court I think it'll
it'll get argued to the Supreme Court
and and and how many years will that
take before The Supreme takes Supreme
Court takes it up I don't know it could
be fast it could be could probably would
be pretty fast concerning uh elections
like that and then what happens if in
Colorado my fear is November uh let's
say October
2024 a state like Michigan will just
take Trump off the ballot and say sue us
then the Trump campaign will sue and
win and then by December 15th they'll
get injunctive relief oh what's that Joe
Biden already won sorry we can't undo
the election it was one state any one
one State's moot true that one state
would have wouldn't have changed the
election but then they then they argue
yes but your honor here's four other
states where it happened too well you
got to take it up with those judges in
those states that has nothing to do with
us it's it's only seven electoral votes
here so you don't win then he's going to
go to that state ah it's only 13 here so
you don't win yeah I just I don't see it
I don't see it getting that far I really
don't I don't I honestly don't think I
can get that far I got to be honest man
you think it's not going to get that far
considering everything we've seen pretty
blacked on a lot of the stuff and I'm
saying I I I would be very surprised if
that if that got that far and i' be very
and I'd be very surprised if it did go
through that it wouldn't take January
surprising too yes of course it should
be surprising every vially surprising I
cannot believe that someone would be
surprised by what is literally happening
right now when you have Colorado
Minnesota and Michigan all happening at
the same time where they're all arguing
Trump should not be on the ballot and a
judge literally donated to a pack to get
Republicans removed from Congress for
supporting Trump I mean we are we are
one centimeter from okay when you have
judge donates money to Target Trump
supporters specifically over January 6
then you have presiding over whether
Trump is eligible for January 6 it is a
slight nudge to Trump ruling Trump is
not eligible there's also there's a huge
difference when we talk about January 6
there's like a huge difference between
the federal courts and in the state
courts too um federal courts always
throw the book entirely at everybody
they have coming in hoping they'll take
a plea deal and like 80 something per of
the people go through federal court take
a ple plea deal because the the
consequences of not taking one are so
high astronomically high that you can
end up in prison for two and a half life
sentences for building an e-commerce
site like Ross HRI right and so like
there's there is a a distinction there
for sure and I don't I just I just don't
see a state court going that far I don't
think I don't think they can I don't
think they I don't I think at some point
someone's going to say judge you
absolutely cannot do this yeah that's
what I think happening right now so when
what's happening now so when the judges
in Pennsylvania ruled that their own
Constitution did not bar them from
passing Universal mail and voting I
don't understand how you go from point A
to point B on that one in in
Pennsylvania a lower Court ruled that
Universal mail and voting violated the
constitution of Pennsylvania Texas filed
their lawsuit the Supreme Court refused
to hear it so there wasn't even a
hearing over what was clearly a
violation of state constitution and the
and the justices of Pennsylvania said we
think absentee ballots and mail and
votes are a different thing so we're
going to allow Universal mail and voting
despite the fact the Constitution
clearly says you can't the upside is
we've got a year to talk about how
insane this crap is yeah that's true we
need elections yeah we have well even if
they're getting twisted behind the
scenes 5149 we still need them look at
Arizona what's what what what happens
with Carri Lake how
many several hundred machines did not
read bouts because the bouts were
printed on the wrong paper the wrong
size printing on the wrong size paper
and but now we're getting into like this
Shadow vote this like this Shad no no no
we're no we're not we're I'll keep it
real simple for you in Arizona it is a
fact no one disputes the voting machines
were not accepting ballots in certain
areas because the wrong siiz image was
printed on the wrong siiz paper
that right there to any honest and
reasonable person is stop stop the
election stop stop stop we got to start
over yeah we don't have to rush
elections these exactly these ballots
are wrong people are complaining if
we're going to have a free and fair
election we got to have uni like it's
got to be Universal and uniform the
ballots instead they said don't no don't
care get out carry Lake but we also got
to remember that this this uh election
fraud thing has been going on for a long
long time it's deeply entrenched right
like it's been deeply entrenched in our
government for many many many years but
this is this is my point this is new and
this is going to be visceral for a lot
of people a lot of people if we know for
a fact that I think it was several
hundred locations in Arizona the bouts
were not properly re being read and they
and they argued no no no we we counted
all of them trust us I'm like no that's
not how elections work this the the
courts I mean k lake is winning very
narrowly in a few areas and it's
advancing now she's running for Senate
so we'll see if there's ever an answer
but I mean they basically just said
everyone knows the election was broken
but we don't care and no one will do
anything about it this is the same
component they're just going and saying
we're going to win through lawfare and
not an actual election and I'm not
putting it past him I don't want anybody
to think that I'm like downplaying this
at all I just if we do nothing they'll
if we do nothing it's definitely what's
going to Happ I do want to stress I'm
not saying it is absolute that they're
going to rule against Trump I don't know
but they're trying and I would not be
surprised at all if they succeed
considering I'll just keep it very
simple the judge in the Colorado case
donated money specifically to remove
Republicans who supported Trump over
January 6 and is now presiding over the
trial to determine whether or not Trump
is ineligible to be president because of
his actions on January 6 I think we know
the biases of this judge I think he
needs to be removed for conflict of
interest well she was accuse herself and
she said oh I don't remember making that
donation don't care what it doesn't
matter that's the thing it was up to her
and there's no oversight she said no no
it's not a conflict of interest I bet
there's a lawsuit hanging in there
somewhere for conflict of interest for
they appeal yeah but my my friends my
fear is first I'll say I I got to stress
you have to go vote you need a Title
Wave of votes you need everyone your
grandmother your kids you know whoever
legally allowed to vote I don't care who
they vote for just go vote yeah go vote
I don't want anyone to be dissuaded from
voting because of these issues but I
want to make sure you understand the
importance of the law fair going forward
that it may be 2 months 3 months four
months before the election one of these
hearings hits a state like Georgia the c
lower court agrees and then orders the
Secretary of State to print bouts
without Donald Trump's name on it Trump
files an appeal the appeal goes to a
higher Court who reverses the decision
secretary of state says okay well now we
got a bunch of belts one way and the
other then the the state appeals or the
or the Democrats appeal and it goes to a
higher court that then says no no no
Trump's ineligible then Trump appeals
and it goes to the Supreme Court who
says you can't take Trump off the ballot
he is eligible and it's a year after the
fact oh so maybe it's good that this is
happening now can get up to the Supreme
Court and they can shut it down it's I
mean if that goes through it's going to
the Supreme Court there's no doubt about
it zero in New York during Co but when
is the question the uh uh Cuomo the
governor shuts down churches he gets
sued saying the first amendment
guarantees our right to assemble you
can't shut down churches this the courts
agree and say you you can't shut them
down they're reopen and he goes okay
I'll make a new executive order slightly
different sue me
again that's the problem even if it
happens now what what's what's happening
now especially with like people like
Sydney pow and Jenna Ellis apologizing
and saying yep we did it we did it
you're now going to have in these
hearing especially in Colorado they're
going to say look here's Trump staff
saying they were instructed to present
misinformation and disinformation for
the purpose of of subverting the
election with fake electors blah blah
blah okay well there's your evidence
then one Court says yes and then they
use it everywhere else it'll have to go
to the Supreme Court but the issue then
becomes what's the Supreme Court is is
the Supreme Court ruling going to be
broad or narrow right well the suem
Court say in the instance of Trump's
eligibility as it pertains to anything
related to January 6 it is not in
dispute Trump did not engage an
Insurrection and is eligible okay or
what they could do is issue a narrow
ruling where they say as to the question
raised specifically by this one group
this one time in Colorado we say that
they are wrong and Trump is eligible and
then what happens another organization
says okay well they didn't answer the
question of January 6 so we're suing
again and then it just keeps happening
until the Supreme Court issues a broad
ruling but I got to tell tell you I
think it's also a strong possibility the
Supreme Court says nah we're not going
to get involved in this one because
states can run their elections as they
see fit in Texas V Pennsylvania 2020
Texas said Pennsylvania violated their
constitution violated the Federal
Constitution by altering the rules of an
election without the approval of the
state legislature and therefore we are
negatively impacted if we are going to
participate in an election everyone has
to have these elections done fairly
Texas is basically saying if our
elections are fair and theirs are not
then the system is broken and the votes
are not legit for I think it was
something like 48 states get involved in
this lawsuit and the Supreme Court said
go f yourselves so the question's never
been answered and now you've got chaos
in in our election system because of
pathetic cowards in the Supreme Court
why didn't I why did they not take that
up did they say thas and Alita were
pissed they issue uh Thomas wrote this
like scathing opinion where he's like we
must take up questions in original
jurisdiction the states need to know
they need these questions answered and
by rejecting this we're leaving the this
question in limbo and now all the states
are in a free-for-all as to what is or
is not constitutional Alo agreed he
wrote his opinion and the rest were like
no we're not getting involved the real
reason was the Supreme Court cowards are
scared that this country is on the brink
you're talking about National divorce of
course yeah you you've got the Boston
Globe story where the Democrats were
proposing West West West uh uh West the
West Coast seceding from the union in
the event of Donald Trump Victory and so
you likely have people like Kavanagh
being like well if I rule on this I mean
it could it could affect history right I
don't want to be involved in that I
don't I don't quit quit right now resign
all of you resign if you're uning to
take up a no they could have taken the
court case and said no you're wrong
Texas the ruling stands Biden's
president they just are cowards and if
you're on Su Court that's kind of your
job to affect history I mean that is why
we put you there SC yeah but when
far-left extremists show up to your
house and threaten to kill you and the
and the police and the judges are like
we're going to let it happen yeah I have
tremendous I have tremendous Sympathy
for the fear on the other other hand if
the fear uh is now too great for you to
complete your job you should step down
if not otherwise you have an obligation
to continue to push for it that's why
these issues AR you have a fiduciary
duty I mean this is you have a duty to
the people to rule on these matters that
make it to the Supreme Court there's no
and because they didn't rule on it the
question remains open and will be an
issue again in 2024 and it's going to be
it's going to be apocalyptic lawfare now
there's going to be like 3,000 lawsuits
everybody who watched 2020 they're
gearing up for law fair right now and
the Democrats are already in it
Republicans are are not going to be as
strong as Democrats on it but they're
gearing up as well it's going to be tens
of thousands of lawsuits what what's the
fix for that public opinion shift in
public
opinion our culture is broken public
it's terrible it's absolutely Terri it's
cultural fragmentation to where these
judges not these ones in Minnesota they
appearer skeptical we'll see what
happens uh and and Minnesota being you
know it's it's not like the furthest of
left States it's you know little it's a
Midwestern so but uh with with Colorado
with California the culture is so
divided let me just put it those the
left is a cult they are uh either
malicious or or um the banality of evil
and they go along with whatever gains
them power so I didn't I didn't mean to
interrupt but what do you think is the
solution building culture that's exactly
why we're doing it now granted I see
these problems I think in the meantime
we need legal uh uh we need law fair you
know return legal fire uh file lawsuits
challenge these things and everyone
needs to vote in a massive Title Wave
but the real solution is always going to
be that politics is Downstream from
culture so what do we need a cast brew
coffee shop in every shopping center I
but this is the truth and I'll tell you
why because right now everybody older
you've got younger people getting their
information from Tik Tok older people
getting their their news from mainstream
media and you're getting propaganda
across the board no one no one is
getting an honest shot you even on on on
YouTube you get you get partisan
propaganda stuff but at least as it
pertains to the quote unquote Freedom
faction I like to say we all try to be
honest about what's going on and then
let people form their own opinions and
and and we have a have a real free and
fair election the reason why we want to
do Casper coffee lady walks into the
coffee shop to buy her coffee and you've
got a TV playing on the wall and guess
what Josh Smith is on doing an interview
now they're hearing another voice now
they're getting a a a wide range of
opinions and Views not just one
hyperarticulated uh opinion and they're
learning about things I I I hope more
people open a whole bunch more brick-and
morar locations but we need to create
spaces in the physical world where
people can meet congregate and hang out
used to be Church it'd be great if it
was we're going to do this Casper coffee
we're going do Saturday morning cartoons
invite families to come and hang out
with their kids and let people start
rebuilding their communities again you
said Josh Smith interview so I'm
listening now you know yeah I think we
need uh to put this show on rumble or
and or I think the YouTube admins should
start shoving this show to the front of
the network but the opposite of that Lu
good luck well yes that is good luck you
should do it because people need to know
about this stuff this needs to become
invigoratingly entertaining YouTube
doesn't want you to know about this
stuff YouTube's not a guy YouTube
Network the Google Executives cried when
Donald Trump won or I should say the
Google Executives held a meeting where
staff cried and they said we will never
let this happen again and we had uh Dr
Robert Epstein on the culture War
explaining it it's really really crazy
how he explains it's not complicated how
they how they can rig elections people
seem to think they hear the story about
Cambridge analytica right right oh they
were they were stealing data from
Facebook they weren't supposed to have
and using that to Target people and
figure out who they were voting for no
it's much simpler than that on Election
Day Mark Zuckerberg sitting there with
his paddle ball went oh can you send out
a notification to all Democrats to go
vote and top Republicans to go watch
Friends yeah but what's happening right
now the people the admins and the
executives are terrifi he found he said
in his data set of tens of thousands of
people he found 100% of Democrats were
given a notification to go vote and only
59% of Republicans got the same mhm you
don't need to trick or convince anybody
you just need to remind one side and not
the other there was that study that uh I
don't remember what University students
did sorry I but it was uh analyzing
Gmail and Gmail would show uh emails
from democratic campaigns but it would
hide or mark spam uh Republican
campaigns I mean this is something that
is aive well and here's the best part
when I think it was Ted Cruz sent a
letter to Google over this he said in
their data set they saw instantly the
the manipulation turned off me that that
indicates Google is intentionally doing
it but what's happening right now people
are terrified Biden screwed this country
hard people know that people are
freaking out that we're going to get
slaughtered because of the this
show of a leadership that we have and
they're willing to open and listen so we
are the voice and we need to inspire
people and and get people excite people
to put this on the front page make
people hear it it's super important we
cannot let go of our elections you know
that we need you this this a team man
people who are watching MSNBC CNN and
Fox News aren't hearing this they they
they're I I don't even I don't even see
anybody tweeting about the Minnesota
case no I like Colorado is getting a
little bit of AirPlay especially because
they showed a clip of this show so we
were like Hey look it's us I saw cash
Patel seems like it's picking up I mean
I was just reading about like Ken bucks
testimony today uh it's getting under
way whereas I mean this true for a lot
of cases when it's the early stages of
like well judge is hearing this whatever
there's sort of less for the journalist
to report on but then when you're able
to say oh Donald Trump Jr and Eric Trump
are reporting today these things might
pick up it is a reason to me it seems
obvious that these these cases are all
hitting at the same time so it's hard to
keep track of them you don't know which
case is presenting what information
because they're arguing very similar
things and different jurisdictions uh
it's intentionally to confuse anyone who
might be trying to follow it so there
again you can retain control of the
narrative that gets out there well now
they have 247 World War III coverage to
watch too to keep them completely in the
dark on everything else would you rather
fight one horse-sized duck or 100
duck-sized horses jeez you know the meme
yeah I know it's silly but here there
actually is a really simple answer a
horse-sized duck you know why you can
run from it yeah so the reason I bring
that up is Donald Trump is currently
fighting 100 duck-sized horses and
they're surrounding them in every
direction that is amazing sorry it and
it's important too because what's
happening right now is a single Democrat
voter in each state files a lawsuit with
only a couple thousand dollar and it
forces Trump's team to expand Nationwide
to every state and set up a legal
operation it's asymmetrical Warfare it
also means that you know and this is not
to be cruel to any of the lawyers
working on these cases but theoretically
the best lawyers that Trump can get
can't be in every single state all the
time so Trump as a single individual in
a single campaign will need to hire
probably 300 lawyers let's be real maybe
that's not even enough okay if you're
talking about election eligibility you
you're not going to have one lawyer do
it you're going to hire a lawyer and
he's going to have a team of like five
or six he's going to need that in every
single state the Democrats no no no no
it's not top down there's one pack in
Colorado that six voters follow a
lawsuit then in Minnesota some random
three random guys follow a lawsuit and
they do it over and over again and and
here and and the crazy thing is there's
going to be different versions of the
same lawsuits filed in multiple States
and Trump as a single entity will
struggle to compete against all of that
sure yeah maximum law fair so what's the
what's the answer for Trump then I mean
what he can't fight all these lawsuits
he has to just fight he has to fight all
the lawsuits and he has to do this and
uh they're going to lie they're going to
cheat and they're going to steal but
once again I tell you first and foremost
everybody needs to vote in a Title Wave
and convince everybody to go vote bring
your friends uh uh uh to vote tell them
you know whatever is legal in your state
you know if you're allowed to ballot
Harvest ballot Harvest you should be
knocking on doors and then uh the real
answer is going to be building culture
don't stuff The Ballot Box illegally
though don't get caught doing that it's
legal in a lot of States people need to
understand that I'll tell you about uh
uh rollerblading is a really great
analogy on this one rollerblading was
the biggest action sport in the world in
the in the in the early 90s had
something like tens of millions of
participants yeah and they did not
Inspire young people to get involved so
10 years goes by and what happens you're
still the best you're a pro you're doing
the bigger tricks better than ever but
there's no one buying any products
around what you're doing no sponsorships
and then finally the X game says guys
you're not selling tickets anymore we're
cutting your event right you're gone
you're still the best in the in the
world but there's no one coming behind
you Republicans need to be inspiring
young people indoctrinating young people
this is the funny thing don't fall for
the left's Trap we absolutely want to
indoctrinate all of the young people
towards values of personal
responsibility meritocracy and Liberty
and the foundation of this country and
all the bad stuff can go away when the
right says oh it's bad the schools are
indoctrinating kids I'm like actually
that would be good if it was like for
American values but it's not it's weird
well garbage yeah I I I I get kind of
caught up on this this Republican
Democrat talk obviously I'm a
Libertarian but the the problem for me
is like all the worst like policy that's
ever passed in my lifetime has always
had bipartisan support but I'm not I'm
not trying to make it seem like
Republicans and Democrats I don't like
the Republican party or the Democratic
party you've got a handful of
Republicans right now seven who are very
Li Arian leaning and populist and so
that's why I'm saying American values if
you believe in the Constitution if you
believe in individual liberties rights
and mocracy that's the indoctrination we
want SC the parties I'm a I'm a
Libertarian American first populist
candidate that's that's what I've been
telling everybody and some of the
Libertarians don't like that I say that
but that's just because they don't
understand what any of those words mean
pretty much what does it mean well
populist is just you're speaking to the
the outside of the ruling Elite right
this regime that like that rules us
through the the Academia and and uh you
know the corporate news media and the
rich and the and the politicians we're
speaking to the middle class and lower
right like these people that are
everyday Americans that get up every
morning and put on their work boots and
go to work that's what a populist
message is speaking to those people not
the not the elite and americ first
here's the thing like Libertarians are
like oh you know anti- borders and and
and oh you can't say America first but
it's like you're running to govern
Americans how could you not be an
American first and in fact if we're
going to be this uh anti- intervention
intervention
right like these anti-war guys then you
have to be America first that's the one
of the most important principles of that
is that we got to stop like meddling in
these foreign interventions yeah it
shouldn't be shameful to be America
first if you're an americ America First
is a good thing if you're running to be
a politician in America and as as a
Libertarian candidate I may be one of
the first guys that actually gets that
and that's you know that's just who I am
well uh your your Chief rival in the
presidential election has a new policy
this story from the post millennial
Trump would create free Freedom focused
on online American Academy as president
and he'd make the woke IVs pay for it it
will be strictly non-political and there
will be no wokeness or jihadism allowed
I see a lot of people cheering for this
but I'm going to be completely honest
this is a stupid idea sorry it just is
uh let me play the video for you recent
weeks Americans have been horrified to
see students and faculty at Harvard and
other once respected universities
expressing support for the Savages and
jihadists who attacked Israel we spend
more money on higher education than any
other country and yet they're turning
our students into Communists and
terrorists and sympathizers of many many
different dimensions we can't let this
happen it's time to offer something
dramatically different under the plan
I'm announcing today we will take the
billions and billions of dollars that we
will collect by taxing fining and suing
excessively large private university
endowments and we will then use use that
money to endow a new institution called
the American Academy its Mission will be
to make a truly worldclass education
available to every American free of
charge and do it without adding a single
dime to the federal debt this
institution will gather an entire
universe of the highest quality
educational content covering the full
spectrum of human Knowledge and Skills
and make that material available to
every American citizen on online for
free whether you want lectures or
ancient histories or an introduction to
financial accounting or training in a
skilled trade the goal will be to
deliver it and get it done properly
using study groups mentors industry
Partnerships and the latest breakthrough
in Computing this will be a truly top
tier education option for the people it
will be strictly non-political and there
will be no wokeness or jihadis ISM
allowed none of that's going to be
allowed most importantly the American
Academy will compete directly with the
existing and very costly 4-year
University system by granting students
degree credentials that the US
government and all federal contractors
will henceforth recognize the academy
will award the full and complete
equivalent of a bachelor's degree in
addition to help the 40 million
Americans who have some college
education but no degree
the American Academy will grant credit
for past coursework at Legacy
institutions and give you the chance to
complete your education at the American
Academy for free and much more quickly
than is now possible or available this
will be a revolution in higher education
and will provide life-changing
opportunities for tens of millions of
our citizens enjoy it learn from it and
thank you I just want I just want to say
real quick the most important thing here
is room tone guys when you're shooting
these videos you need to record about 30
seconds of what's called room tone
silence so that you can mask the jump
Cuts but anyway what were you saying is
this like a a GED but for a bachelor's
degree instead of high school diploma
and I think look I I can respect the
colleges are garbage they're making kids
Communists but the government making
another program is not the solution yeah
this is the this is the same dilemma you
had when you were talking about the
Central Bank digital currencies except
with education
exactly oh the government's going to
swop and create Government College for
you don't worry Trump says it won't be
woke no way he'll get out of office and
then some crackpot woke person will bang
the gavl and it'll turn into woke you
and then the government's funded it it
can never die can never go away no he
likes to say that everything woke turns
to but really it's everything the
government touches turns to it's
also the government touches the puts the
woke in it yeah he's saying you know I
want people to have opportunities to get
whatever but why don't we just stop
giving out student loans I I feel like
that's the thing that I'm more
interested in seeing right I mean there
are tons to college we stop subsidizing
the whole system entirely it doesn't it
doesn't make you could solve a lot of
issues that way in fact you could make
College affordable I do love how he came
out with his own right-wing version of
free college for all though that's
hilarious and if and if he fails at at
president we'll definitely see the ads
on Facebook where he's like you know
give us your email address and we'll
send you an email subid do this for free
subsidizing college was one of the
biggest mistakes this our society ever
made yes because what happens now is
young person says oh I can get a loan to
go to college I'll learn uh I'll take
something I don't even know most kids
don't even know what their Major's going
to be I don't even know my major is
going to be then why are you going so
they go thinking they're going to get a
job that kid that that 17-year-old I say
kid because they're 17 they're planning
College they turn 18 they go to college
if they just went and got a job working
at their like local with a handyman true
loc local local mechanic engineer
electrician they said I'm just going to
do go for work heating and air
conditioning they'd learn real skills
that translate they' have an actual ual
job and then they can figure things out
as they're getting older or they can
work work these skills and maybe I don't
know being electrician is a great skill
to have and they could have learned that
they didn't have to go to college they
go to trade school or something instead
they graduate four years later and go
oops you know what's a better idea than
going to Trump's uh America school it's
just running for your local school board
and changing the school district in your
own in your own locality literally it's
it's going to be just as easy you could
change everything if they never
subsidized College young people would
not have and wasted their time
generating debt and then learning there
there are so what happens is I read this
great article this is when I was a kid
they said you need an IQ of at least
one0 to go to college and the problem is
subsidized universities is telling
everyone of any capability to go to
college you end up with people who are
not bright enough who can't understand
the material I think we were talking
about the other day like college was
supposed to be you sat down and
experimented and worked with like-minded
individ individuals and you wrote a
thesis you were saying this and now it's
jened now it's like here's your homework
come back it's like being in high school
I mean and this is also different than
let's say like the British system right
like in the equivalency of high school
in England you are already narrowing
down what you want to study in America
we keep students taking everything for
as long as possible and now that
basically lasts until they you know if
you enroll in college at 18 that's the
first two years of college so when
you're 20 you are still taking General
classes as instead of specializing in a
skill yeah but the longer you're in the
more money you owe the government
exactly I mean that's the thing about
subsidizing is that you were able to say
to colleges name your price and we will
write a blank check and we will for them
to agree to take it that's crazy that
also means that there's no uh incentive
for colleges to say hey we're going to
make this quick and efficient for you I
mean there are schools that will say oh
well we're revamping our general Ed
criteria so actually you can't graduate
unless you take you know summer courses
which cost additional money or you you
spend an extra year here I mean they're
trying to make it last as long as
possible because they don't care that
you're going into debt and in fact while
I was sitting here my college called me
to try and get a donation this is just
you know that you will always be a meal
ticket for and I think it's sad because
there are probably professors who are
really dedicated to things that they're
interested in you know there are
students who are genuinely interested in
learning it's the administration well
and also if we did not have college
would you have you know people who spend
money buying tickets to lectures instead
like right now we trap all of learning
in college when it doesn't have to be
that way you KH Academy you can do all
kinds of things I mean you can get free
lectures online as it is I don't know
why we need American Academy except for
the fact that now they're saying you
could potentially get the equivalency of
a GED but for your bachelor's so if you
gotten some college somewhere but also
to what end if you've been able to find
a good job be after having left College
why would you then go back and get a
degree except for like I guess wanting
to seem sort of elite and good I don't
really get what the benefit of this is
uh I like that he said they would rush
you could rush through so kids that are
really smart and they want to work 10
hours a day can get their degree in a
year you can do that with en programs
while you're in high school I mean you
can get I've known kids who graduate
high school with their AA degree if
they're getting dual enrollment during
college credit like through their local
Community College there are tons of ways
to go through college faster I think we
don't talk about them because ultimately
everyone wants you on this pipeline
where you go into de yeah yeah but
you're talking about things that don't
need college for things where you need
to get a degree like being a doctor for
instance you're not going to do it
online you have to go and do medical
practice and and rounds you have to
learn how to actually save lives you
should be able to do it online though
medical work yeah sure you because uh
you got to learn how to
would you go to a doctor that got his
his education online no of course not so
of course not nobody would this is the
information age we know if we know where
somebody so you think the average person
would then it's it's the responsibility
of the individual to check onto the the
the practice I don't dise you could
learn a lot of the information um the
book information online but then you do
need to go practice you got have Labs if
you're I had a friend in high school who
put himself through college while uh
working as a paramedic all four years
and or first TR I can't remember in EMT
um if he wanted to be a doctor shouldn't
he automatically get real word credit
like it he doesn't she shouldn't have to
take certain classes because he has the
practical skills I get that eventually
maybe he has to go to Medical there's a
big difference between an EMT and a
Doctor by the way but like at the same
time he's had more hands-on experience
any kid who anyone who just took a
biology class right there should be some
recognition of Real World skills I think
if you get if you're a do if you're good
at it and it took you two years to
become an expert doctor I'd rather have
you than a guy who was 12 years in
school and doesn't know what he's doing
I really don't care about these things I
mean that's why there are like
standardized tests that all of them go
through to say yes I am now a good
doctor I am qualified to be a good
doctor when I say I want the government
out of Education I don't just mean my
kids education I mean all education
entirely that's why I'm like never
should have been involved in education
Trump saying free University is that's
exactly what he's trying to do it's
terrible but there's something like you
don't want one School teaching that 2
plus 2 equals 5 and another school
teaching that equals four you got to
have some government oversight because
then everyone will be would you put your
kid in the school that teaches 2 plus 2
equal 5 I wouldn't but if my parents
thought it equaled five they probably
would have put me in that school yeah
well and so we have a federal government
that's like no we're going to have some
standardization terrible kids aren't
standardized at all well some of it like
you ever you ever been around children
yeah they're all different everyone yeah
but if they were being taught that words
meant different things that would be a
big problem so we need some
standardization otherwise we'd go to war
we need that standardization only
because children uh parents have become
entirely disinterested with their
children's education that's the only
problem they're disinterested in their
kids yeah entirely also if a schools
wanted to tweak kids and there was no
government oversight they could like
make little terrorists or make people
think the wrong things slightly the
Govern is doing this now in a bunch of
States well that's a problem the
government is the biggest purveyor of
what you're talking about I think the
government's too involved but I don't
think no government in education be no
government in education at all at all
100% there used to be no there used to
be no government in education and kids
could go to their local schools they
could go to any school they wanted to
they learned all the all the things that
helped build this this country without
the government Nanny State telling them
what they had to do in education what
year oh I don't know the federal
government got involved in the 70s but
the states have been involved for quite
some time but prior to that the state
governments weren't involved in
education know when they I don't doe
that's the department of Ed that's but
there there's been State involvement in
schools much longer than that but not
that much longer than that 1867 was the
Office of Education yeah yeah that's
probably because the Civil War happened
and they were like we can't let that
happen again we need to teach these
people same
thing I don't know I think just
ultimately the government doesn't want
you to have uh an independent life
outside of its perview right and so
maybe it was a civil war but ultimately
as soon as they started saying hey it
turns out we can have a say in your
domestic life if we mandate that your
children go to school right there there
has always been an a tendency toward
creeping reach into influence and I
think the issue is ultimately that the
government doesn't know better than
parents I could get the argument that
you want to say that information is
standardized but knowing that 2 plus 2
equals 4 is basic logic I mean that's
irrefutable I live in Iowa it's like one
of the the most free education states in
the country I mean as far as uh uh
education Freedom goes you can
homeschool your children and you don't
have to tell the government anything at
all you can just petition your local
school district when they're 18 and you
think they've gone far enough to get
them their diploma so like do you think
the government should come in and tell
us we can't do we can't home schol our
kids anymore the way that we are I don't
know it depends on what you're teaching
them I guess why cuz if you're teaching
them that killing is good that's a big
problem murder is good that would be a
big problem murder murder is illegal so
if my kids kill somebody they're going
to get they're going to get arrested
that's already illegal but if like a
state was teaching their kids like it's
okay to steal this like there are La you
just said a state though that's a that's
a government yeah if there were children
within a state all being self- schooled
to think that things that were legal
were legal like you need some some
oversight of of some structure we don't
have any and I will at all and
everybody's just fine some of the only
compelling argument I've ever heard for
having you know minimal in government
involvement with homeschooling and
because you know I would doesn't have
any but some states have more than
others so you can look these up online
they'll be you know blogs or whatever
that rate it like New York state has
high regulation it's very difficult to
homeschool in New York uh West Virginia
is sort of middle tier and one of the
things that comes up when you regulate
with homeschooling or when you enrolling
home schooling is some states require
you to do a certain number of
standardized tests to prove that your
kid is learning or meeting certain
criteria or you have to submit your
curriculum some some state governments
required that I contend that putting the
the government into education has had a
huge hug the only time I've ever heard
anyone make a compelling argument was
this one social worker who said the
thing is I just wouldn't want a student
to not be enrolled in any school and for
us who never know what happened to them
and I find that interesting because
they're making a direct uh like child
welfare argument right like if if a kid
is in a you know domestically violent
home if they just get lifted out of the
system if they never go to school you
wonder what happened when you do hear
case like that but to me that speaks the
fact that we don't have strong
communities around them that would let
children just fall off the map yep and
that's what I was going to say it's it's
definitely contributed to the downfall
of like strong families and strong
communities entirely just putting just
putting the government in education at
all and forcing families into education
uh kids if you if a kid doesn't go to
school they'll arrest the parents yes
that's crazy it's kind of like this is a
good uh piece of the argument of
centralization versus decentralization
and we need some of both I mean I think
I I air towards decentralization is on a
whole but without any centralization we
would have no federal Authority we would
have no State we' have no United States
states wouldn't be United because there
was no Central Authority you don't have
to sell it to me I'm already a
fan a bunch of small small states
instead of one big country yeah I've
heard 5,000 lickstein buddy yeah
absolutely that's that's from Hans
Herman hopp himself I think one of the
hard things about the balance and I I
always had a hard one of the struggles I
had with Libertarians is that I was
really interested in uh foster care and
seeing foster care reform but ultimately
the question is always like does the
government get to say you're a bad
parent although we know there are people
who should not be parenting who are not
safe parents who are you know at what
point do we intervene and what
frustrates me is that Libertarians
always F back on aren't there churches
or nonprofits to to uh fix that but we
know of course any institution of power
could be potentially corrupt and it's
very CH challenging to deal with
children and so I think you come into
the same kind of obstacles with uh
questions about education which is that
as much as there are lovely strong
parents who even if they don't know
something they are willing to push and
help their students there are also
parents who just don't care and who have
these kids who are they are ultimately
not that interested in or they're
detached from and how do you make sure
those students have you know so
something better yeah we adopted we
adopted two we have we have two adopted
kids they're actually my oldest
daughter's younger siblings and um part
of that when we adopted them from
Arkansas part of that deal was that they
had to be in some type of public
education when we got wow yeah and uh
but thankfully we're in Iowa where they
have Community Choice Charter Schools
which are Super Community Based you have
the opportunity to go down and be a part
of the curriculum you get to join the
administration team and all kinds of
stuff and so we were able to use those
because we live in Iowa as a public
school and they they got a better
education that way but even then they
were like my my son was nine when we got
him and he had um never been to school
at 9 years old not a single day of
school nobody had taught him nothing he
taught himself how to read in the back
of a car mhm wow and so we you know
putting him in the public education
system was very hard for him like
extremely hard for him because they were
like well he's supposed to be in fourth
grade we want to put him in fourth grade
I'm like Whoa man he's never been to
school you know and so we had to like do
a bunch of wraparound programs and I was
at school with him and my wife was at
school with him and and you know it took
him some time but he's caught up now
it's in seventh grade um but you know if
we had had the chance to just homeschool
him we could have got him through it a
lot better and maybe more smoothly yeah
much more smoothly with less with less
frustration from him too but
homeschooling is a big I mean I I think
homeschooling is great you know I family
members to home school but it's not
without its sacrifices right it's an
extremely difficult thing to do I
understand that there are families that
rely on you know a community school or
some or a public school in town because
otherwise they can't work jobs or do
whatever they need to do uh it's the
fact that ultimately the state knows
that that's where families are
vulnerable and sees as a place to you
know influence your children when you
need Community Support I mean that's
what theoretically your local elementary
school should be it was like Dewey who
kind of started this this really like
this Dewey the of the the federal like
really like authoritarian School
structure that we have now I think it's
gone too far I think we're going to
Super chats I could tell Tim's about to
raise the bar dang well let's go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to Tim
cast.com click join us cuz the members
only uncensored show is going to be lit
and we'll take calls from you our
members and you can talk to us on our
guest Christopher Lambert wins the first
Super Chat of the day he says I fell
asleep well you did but you beat
everyone else to the first Super Chat
congratulations Sammy spills the te says
absolutely love this podcast and all
that you do Tim the crew you have is
amazing thank you the crew is amazing
they do excellent work in making all
this possible grafty Pops in S I will be
waiting for a few minutes but I'm here
thank you all right Timmy J says Eric
Ericson called you and Candace Owens
anti-semites on his podcast today he
said he don't know you enough Eric
Ericson who is that I don't know you I'm
really sick I don't know him enough to
comment on that I'm really sick of
people saying anti stuff the anti-semite
thing just makes me laugh done anti crap
I'm done with it it doesn't mean
anything tell me what you are yeah I
honestly don't care if you call me an
anti-semite or a Nazi or any of that
stuff I'm still going to give you my
entire like truthful opinion on
geopolitics no matter what you call me I
don't care anyone saying that that's
just like your opinion man like you can
say
I've been called an anti-semite more
over the last 3 weeks than I ever have
in my entire life ever and it's only
because I'm like hey maybe children
shouldn't be dying for your Wars of of
politics right like it's it's absolutely
insane crazy position out there the
Palestinians are semites too yes that's
the other thing they are a lot of Arabs
are semites as well it's just a it's all
about language it's really what it is
most of these labels don't mean anything
because they get thrown around all the
time anyways well it's so funny to me
because obviously Israel's huge right
now this is a big giant topic right but
like they're they've always framed it at
least for most of my life as this giant
holy war we were talking about this
before the show but it's not a holy war
it's not the Muslims versus the Jews
it's the zionists versus the
Palestinians it's a war it's a political
war 100% it's a political war yeah
meaning that it's the the state is
trying to take land they have I mean
they have been if you look at the
history of the sinist they' they've they
and the funny thing too is first of all
this this Divine claim to Israel Israel
is actually in the Bible it is the
descendants of Abraham it's a citizen a
citizenship of the heart for anybody who
accepts Christ as the Messiah and the
people who live there today do not
accept Christ as the Messiah well that's
but that the Jews don't follow the New
Testament right so right but they're
saying that they have this divine right
to to in their book they do well and but
you got to understand that um to say
that that's Israel when it wasn't Israel
it was Palestine right but it was isra
and prior to that it was the land of
Canan right it was ayria before that it
was Assyria before that it was the
Ottoman Empire I mean you're talking
you're talking thousands of years here
you know so so again once again I it's a
weird thing for me because Max blumthal
brought this up he was like the this is
it was Palestine and before that it was
the descendants of of the Jews who were
conquered by Muslims and I was like okay
so the Jews are Conquering the land back
like that bro there's no argument of
someone being like you want a Hatfield
to McCoy this thing all the way back to
the dawn of time fine so be it but if
your argument is it was conquered before
so therefore it's Palestine I'm like oh
okay so they're getting conquered now
sounds like the colonizers are getting
colonized and they're getting come up is
that is that the argument no but you got
but you do also have to understand when
the Zionist moved in to to Israel they
were living with the Muslims right but
there was also Christians that live
there that have been displaced as well
and there still today 7% of Palestine is
is Christians right now the third oldest
church in the entire world none of that
matters it do it does it I think it does
matter I think when you're talking about
the GE politics of it if if in this
lifetime in this generation and the last
generation those people lived on that
land too and they got dis these these
these don't present any solutions to the
conflict it's come in and choose a side
and then start fighting about it instead
of being like I want to choose a side at
all you really want to distinguish
Israeli and Jew it's very important
they're two completely different the
country of Israel and the Zion meaning
the people that wanted to create a
country of Israel it's totally different
than someone that's Jewish they're not
the same in any there's a lot of Jews
today and and we saw there's video of it
all over today that there's Jews being
beat in the street by Zionist police for
protesting against the dead children in
Palestine right now it's happening right
now do you know that for sure yeah I saw
the videos of it I watched the videos of
it watching a video doesn't mean you
know why why the fight happened well and
so fed up with all of the lies okay
there's no refugee camp that a lie on
both sides what what was what was the
what was the LIE from Israel I mean
there's they no I'm not saying they're
none I mean like I can tell you examples
we have right now well how about this
how about this I know they're saying
that war war was declared on October 7th
right by Hamas I nobody's going to
dispute that okay I think I think
Netanyahu is the one who declared the
war sure but well come on they Hamas
attacked Hamas atted War but do you know
that since January of this
year in times of Peace 200 Palestinians
have been killed by IDF right I don't I
don't know that matters does it does yes
because Hamas flew over tore down
fencing exec killed a bunch of civilians
in October 7th October 7th and then
saying something like 200 Palestinians
down I'm like okay what
happened how how many how many Hamas
soldiers died on October 7th I don't I
don't know you should know right I mean
if you're going to use this as an
argument because the argument no I'm not
this isn't my argument my argument is
that these tensions have been going on
for for years and years and years and
years and they've been killing both
sides have been killing each other for a
long time yeah yeah but there's a big
difference between like over the span of
several months for a reason we have not
yet determined 200 Palestinians died it
doesn't answer how many Israelis died it
also doesn't correlate with and Israel's
prior to to to January as well and and
palestine's prior to that and and and
Israel is prior to that and that's and
that's why that number doesn't mean
anything there's you can't it doesn't
mean anything so when I say that the
history of the region in terms of like
it was this country before this country
before this country doesn't solve the
problem today sure so you've got Israel
and Palestine fighting we say what's the
solution to stop the conflict right now
okay well Hamas attacked Israel on
October 7th in in a in a brutal a
horrifying way now Israel is a striking
Gaza thousands of of civilians are dying
if so so you've I I think there's a fair
argument for ceas fire only in the
context of we do not want regional
conflict which is happening it's
starting it's already yeah it's already
we're hospital is firing shells today I
mean it's and then and then the houthis
in Yemen are are launching Iran's
backing all of them and now it's it's
pulling everybody and plus Israel's been
bombing Syria this is bubbling up it's
getting massive the only reason to call
for a ceasefire is not because of a
moral stance on who is allowed or not to
do it it's because guys stop fighting
before the whole world BL We're not
gonna get a ceasefire and do you want to
hear my conspiracy theory on this this
is a conspiracy theory I have nothing to
back this up but the West has wanted
wanted war with Iran for a long time
that's undisputable right and how how so
so putting boots on the ground West
Western boots on the ground in Palestine
is going to they're doing it hugely yes
and it's going to hugely increase the
chances of terrorist attacks in the west
which is exactly what happened on 9/11
that gave them all the support they
needed to going to Afghanistan Iraq
Syria later Yemen all these places that
they needed to go right this this this
uh what was 11 countries or whatever
that they wanted to go to war with they
they know 100% that when they put boots
on the ground in Palestine there's going
to be there's going to be terrorist
attacks in the west they're already
there they're going to get the support
that they need for for war with Iran
that's speci it is a fact according to
the New York Times And The Times of
Israel that US Special Forces are in
Israel assisting with recovery of
hostages now that's the extent of the St
but you'd be insane not to think that as
isra exactly they don't stand there in
Li with Israel they go get them right
and with Israel now cutting Gaza in half
the assumption is US forces are already
fighting plus there have been reporters
on the ground who have stated this
already rumors because it's hard to
confirm these things but if the official
reporting is special forces are there
then reporter says Hey Americans are in
Gaza fighting it stands to reason that's
likely the case the according to
Bloomberg the US held secret uh meetings
discussing US troops occupying Gaza
after this operation ends so yes right
Iran they know we should go deep on the
after show on Israel Palestine conflict
I want to go deeper yeah we can go
deeper on it for sure there's a lot I
got a lot more to say let's read some
more so I looked up ericon he's a
personality Hello whoa what was that
what was that
awesome your phone no that was uh we're
in the Discord Channel someone went oh I
see yeah why are we in the Discord
Channel That's not supposed to happen
well that was terrifying yeah just a
bright hello from someone who popped in
and there you
go yeah sorry with that well there you
go let's read uh Eric Ericson is like a
conservative personality whatever I
think it's funny that I'm getting a
bunch of people calling me an Israeli
Zionist chill and then Eric Ericson
allegedly according to this tweet is
calling me an anti-semite or something
yes either way there there's no there's
nothing you can do about it I guess no
one happy you've been like pretty you've
been pretty pro-israel to be be calling
it anti-site right I mean I I'm pro
Israel in the extent of October 7th like
I'm not going to get into the history of
the region and I can only tell you now
that when people make moral arguments
about what Israel did in the past versus
what Hamas did on October 7th or what
Israel's doing right now too I'm just
like this none of this is solving
anything right you know and and then
they're like yeah well Israel's right to
defend itself blah blah blah and I'm
like sure like I'm not saying you're
wrong but this is not going to solve any
of the problems no it's going to make it
much worse it's all going to get way
worse so I don't have any moral answers
for anybody other than Hamas did a whole
bunch of awful things and then the left
keeps lying about all of it right and so
what what what bothers me is that oh a
hospital was bombed psych not really oh
a refugee camp was bombed psych not
really and then I'm like I'm done and
then they're like yeah well Israel is
bombing civilians I'm like yeah but all
of those stories turn out to be lies no
they're definitely there's a lot of
course of course except the two big ones
that were were cast belly for these
other countries and militia groups to
get involved were fake and I'm just like
at this point I'm done listening to
people who in their own Doctrine say lie
to me to gain political power I don't
care about Israel like they're a country
that exists there's a war going on you
should care more about I care about
Israel as much as I care about May
because Israel has a ton of influence on
your politics here in the United States
and I care about Israel as much as I
care about Myanmar and Armenia are there
problems in our me with the Christians
you bet it's horrifying we should talk
about it I care about Israel as much as
that and these other countries nobody's
talking about those countries The
Psychotic psychotic psychotic obsession
with Israel is the most annoying thing
in the world to it's just like
you there are some people who just
cannot talk about anything else and I'm
like geez you you you have people on
Twitter that we'll have a calm rational
conversation with you about anything and
then as soon as Israel come comes up
they'll start talking about nuking Gaza
and I'm like oh yeah and calling you an
anti-semite if you don't want any dead
children to and I'm like can we talk
about Burma you're not passionate about
Burma I mean like or Yemen Yen my top
passion 1948 the Burma Myanmar conflict
200 plus thousand dead nobody cares yeah
the theen I mean the Yemen humanitarian
crisis just just stopped like literally
500,000 dead children due to foreign
policy like US foreign policy in Saudi
Arabia and like nobody said a word I
always say this our priority should be
what's happening in the US it's not you
can't be compassionate or empathetic to
what's going on outside the US but how
can we have this conversation about what
we should be doing in in an
interventionist fashion when we don't
secure our own border it's ridiculous
let's read some more we got this uh
Bender the offender says Tim I do not
think that a majority of States would
abolish or ban no fault divorce due to
the fact that states get a financial
percentage of the from the divorcees
however I did see that the GOP was going
after no fault divorce thoughts no fault
divorce should be abolished and I
believe that along along with it it will
take child support with it I think child
support is overwhelmingly a really
really awful and evil thing title 4D of
the Social Security Act this is part of
my platform for so the the lamest most
basic terms for title 4D of the Social
Security Act is
for every 66 cents that a state spends
on child support enforcement um welfare
programs stuff like that the federal
government returns them a dollar for
every 66 cents they spend so essentially
what the federal government has now done
has subsidized the state to separate
families so they can treat one custodial
parent that has the child all the time
and one as a visitor so they can take
revenue from them and for every dollar
they collect from them or or for every
66 cents they collect from them the the
federal government gives them a dollar
back but also through no fault divorce
and other things as as including these
programs that the states have we've
incentivized women most of the time
96.7% of the time it's the woman to
split up the family and get paid and you
have to pay for her life and your
child's life and your own life and then
you get to see your child every every
other Sunday night child support in
almost all almost all forms should be
abolished because it is an incent it is
an incentive and a safety net to tell
anyone but typically women that if you
break up your family for for with no
fault the man is on the hook you have a
don't worry about it y title 4D of the
social CU act will take care of a lot of
that divorce should be only in the
instances of fault abuse infidelity and
if a uh it will be typically be men if a
man is abusing his wife sorry buddy you
got to pay child support and a lot if a
guy is uh uh committing infidelity you
broke the rules you broke the terms of
your agreement you got to pay child
support but if you have a men and women
who are married and Omen just says I'm
not into it anymore I'm getting a
divorce and you have to pay nope that
should be abolished and the guy should
be like well you chose to break the
family up here's how it should work
joint custody and then the guy says I'll
pay for the kids when I have the kids
and you pay for the kids when you have
the kids no question there should be no
incentive equal responsibility equal
responsibility and no incentive for for
anyone to get a divorce knowing the
other partner typically the man has to
pay for it I talked a lot about this on
the last show I was on with you already
but the uh the amount of fathers homes
in America is one and four mhm one in
four kids lives in a fatherless home 82%
of all violent youth offenders sitting
in jail today today are from a
fatherless home 92% of mass Shooters are
from a fatherless home these are
undeniable this was Larry Elder's big
thing he announced kany he let off the
fact that the fatherless epidemic is the
thing driving social destruction in
America the worst part of is the worst
absolute worst thing that we face as
Americans today it is bred an entire
generation of apathetic violent children
and I mean we could change the culture
and the stats are undeniable and and we
have to but we'd have to acknowledge
that this is an issue and you'd have to
fight the idea that like no it's great
if we have you know unmarried couples
single moms who depend on the government
which is obviously not what one party in
particular wants I want to read this uh
federali actual says I'm literally out
of discretionary funds but had to tip
One Last Time hearing that Tim is hiring
skaters who speak out keep going guys
spiral out and vote for Josh Smith was I
first you were far from first but I want
to stress this point yes I I I don't
know if it's up yet but it's called The
Boonies it's our skate show we were just
having a meeting over the new Skate Park
Designs we are bringing on a series of
pro skaters we filmed with a bunch of uh
Semi-Pro AMS and we're doing tips for
tricks cash two skateboarders oh it is
the most glorious thing ever because
there are some skateboarders who are
just cowards absolute cowards and
they're like I'm scared to come and
skate your park because then someone
might yell at me on the internet and I'm
like then there's no money here for you
but it's your choice then there are
other skaters who like I don't care
people on the internet say let's go and
they show up and do awesome tricks the
point of this is you know the hardest
thing in the culture war is inspiring
young people sure so many people uh like
I don't have kids working on it none of
your business but um because everyone's
always like where are your kids well
it's a private family matter but not
that you're asking uh but making sure
that the Next Generation holds our
values is quite literally the the the
Apex of our mission that's the only
thing that matters true you can say
right now I wish the system was this way
what you need to be saying and
understanding is the system changes when
you share those ideas with young people
who can then start working towards
expanding those ideas as they grow older
and growing into it if you do nothing
they're all Communists also let me say
uh if you're waiting to for things to
get better to have children don't
they're not going to get any better you
got to have kids now right now yeah the
guy who had who had seven kids while
living in the middle of the woods 300
years ago was not waiting for it to get
better no actually the kids were making
better he was like we need kids who can
help do work if we're going to survive
build a tribe strong men create good
times and uh you can only make strong
kids if you're if you're having him but
so this is the point when federali says
he's out of money but he's tipping
anyway I really do appreciate it and I
just want to stress this is the the
point this is the mission we were we
were talking about you know money before
the show and I'm like man if I just did
my one YouTube channel my in the morning
and the Morning Show podcast I am
wealthy and I have the rest of the day
off and I don't got to worry about any
respons responsibility instead I've
decided to take on a whole bunch of
extra work to try and build culture
music skateboarding coffee shop whatever
we can because that's the key path to
Victory and it is arduous it is
strenuous it is stressful but it's worth
it uh that is not I I don't want to
anyone get the wrong impression
obviously building a company builds my
net worth at the same time it's like I'm
just flushing money down the toilet but
there's a lot of other easier things I
could do with all the money made from
just one YouTube channel and just
programmatic ads yeah but if you just
sit around and do that they'll make cbdc
and then ban you for saying something
they like you got to move got exactly
exactly yeah then I don't know I just I
just feel like doing it diversify your
portfolio if someone if someone said
your personal Port yeah your ability
portfolio here's a lesson I learned a
long time ago I'll ask you right now if
you woke up tomorrow and you had a
million dollars Clean Cash in your bank
account what would you do invest 75% of
it so there's three three tiers of
answers that so this is a question
typically asked of like uh Venture
capitalists there's three three tiers of
the answers one is the the ideal answer
is the direct response of oh man a
million bucks we are looking at this new
property where we can start producing
more of our product if I had 300,000
that's the answer they're looking for
the second answer is what you said I
would invest okay well it's a little
vague but that's good because it means
if I give you money you're looking to
make money with it and the worst answer
which is 95% of the answers is oh man
vacation vacation like oh dude I'd get a
new car and I'd pay off my bills and
it's like I will never give you a penny
yeah and so when people ask if someone
were to ask me like if you if you were
given a million dollars to him right now
what would you buy with it I'd be like I
just hire someone to make a couple
documentaries try and win the culture
War I guess that's literally the only
thing I care about true you know I could
I could live in a van down by the river
and be happy but in terms of what I want
to buy with things is people doing
awesome stuff to win just also remember
the the other most important thing you
can do to win the culture war is to have
children and raise them to be
freethinking independent humans yeah
very very important going places you
don't normally go and interacting with
people you don't normally interact with
is vastly powerful yeah it can be for
sure absolutely all right here we go
let's read some more Riley Leen says Ian
Freeman was sentenced to 96 months in
federal prison for selling Bitcoin
without sufficient investigations into
his willing customers in early October
not the first or the last unfortunately
yeah there's a few the the the crypto 6
or something like that from New
Hampshire he was part of that and I
don't know all the details of the of the
cour case so I'm not going to comment on
it too much but I know Ian Freeman has a
a podcast community that he puts my
podcast on for me all the time he's
pretty cool guys Reeb chep says to be
honest 2,000 isn't enough this is in
reference to a video I made where a
woman says she'll she won't sleep with a
man until he spends two grand on her and
I said she's right he says you shouldn't
sleep with a man unless he also buys you
a $9,000 Shiny Rock and swears in front
of both your families to love you
forever bingo I don't know about the
$9,000 Shiny Rock and the money isn't
necessarily what's important this woman
wrote an article where she was like I
heard that some women are saying they'll
only sleep with a man if he spends
$2,000 on her and she's like I think
it's probably a good idea cuz I've sleed
with a bunch of guys and then they
ditched me the next day and if I wait
until they spend this money maybe
they'll stick around and I'm like women
are starting to ReDiscover standards
again I know it's crazy thank goodness
full circle she she says at the end of
the article actually what's more
important than the money is what is it
what is their job do they have debt did
they go to school do they have a stable
career what's their future plans and I'm
like's relationship like with their F
their family their parents and I'm like
these are all the questions we always
asked and then we got rid of it for
hookup culture and now you're realizing
that was bad and hooking up with random
guys was bad and now you're like maybe I
should actually stop ask these guys
about their lives and if they don't
stick around they weren't worth it in
the first place I think women are also
discovering that when you have standards
for men men men like to meet the
standards they like they like to pursue
and achieve right so if I say like I
want to be withone who's High achieving
that's for someone who also wants to be
high achieving and that is better for
both of us in the long run if you're
expecting very little and the man
doesn't have to do anything like maybe
he'll hang around for a while but
ultimately he is dissatisfied with his
life anyways and will'll move on it's
it's not a it doesn't benefit anyone to
have low standards sure I I said the
other day all this stuff popped up
originally with that tweet of the I
don't know what was it $200 on the first
dat or whatever yeah you you retweeted
my my tweet but I I said when I stopped
dating for a fun time and started dating
for a long time I stopped having dates
that didn't need reservations and that
true like when when I when I wanted that
quality like I changed my whole life to
go get quality I've been getting into
Chastity lately which is just really sex
with a purpose like instead of just lust
true it's it's stressful cuz
testosterone's nuts but like it's it's
really rewarding you got to meditate you
got to discipline you have to be the
warrior you know there's or get married
there's two kind people there's the you
can do it whenever you want the person
who's the who's the look you're either
in control of yourself or you're being
controlled by your by whims right when
you when you wake up do you decide I
like I am me and I decide what I do or
do you just face compulsion within you
and say I'll I'll do whatever I feel you
know what I mean I think the things you
do in life should have purpose and
dating is one of those things are you an
NPC or are you a player character I'm a
player character that mean means you
when your body says I want a large
chocolate cake you say I'm not eating
that yeah when your body says I don't
feel like working out you say you're
damn right you're working out yeah
that's kind of nice that's what Rogan
said he has a great quote where he's
like I think it's Rogan where he said
that inner says no I don't feel
like working out you got to beat it into
submission and then go work out beat it
earlier into submission body yeah all
right here I love this one the real
Hydro PX we don't read enough for your
super chats he says Tim is such a
pompous person who thinks the people
around him don't understand things it's
it's his insecurities from not having a
GED I I I had to read it cuz I love it
and real Hydro I really do appreciate it
I think you've given me like $5,000 at
this point from just blasting these
super chats all day every day just
insulting me is he right he's not right
okay is he talking about when you
explain things that you know everyone
involved in our conversation listening
at home may not NE like when you
explained whatever the the uh CB acronym
yeah like is that I think he's talking
about guest or something some people in
the chat were like what's cbdc that's
why yeah youcast host the comedian Josh
Denny redheaded guy he was on the Food
Network for a while he's been really
canceled from a lot of I had him on my
show once and he's got like this
dedicated group of like troll haters
that will go to any media that he does
and super chat questions to to make fun
of him and before the show he goes
listen you're going to get all kinds of
super chats of people asking me
questions that are derogatory calling me
Uber driver and all these things ask
every one of them he said he said stay
on for 3 hours and get you every Super
Chat you need I was like all right man
let's do it I sounds fun and we did we
sat there it was great he's like for his
own ticket out there he paid he paid for
every everything yeah absolutely I first
of all I the the the main reason I don't
read a lot of hydro's super chats is
because there's too many of them and I I
try to read a bunch of different ones uh
but I also have no problem reading super
chats from people who don't like me I
think that's kind of the point too but I
do think it's just like this one was
particularly good
like I don't have a g or whatever I'm
literally complaining about school
saying stop going like the
multi-millionaire who doesn't have a GD
I mean Tim CRI himself to sleep about it
his life is a ruins it's not it's not
that I'm just begging people to stop
going to school and it's like haha you
wish you did and I'm like I genuinely
want the school system to be destroyed
that's why I like that one cuz I have
such a heart on for hating
institutionalized learning facilities
that one really I got my GD went in the
military like a dumb Dum G what does it
even mean like dude good enough diploma
it's it's but it's not even it look I I
I don't know I don't know where I learn
this how I learn this but if you can
convince someone you don't need anything
you know you can you can walk into any
venue you want meet any celebrity you
want so long as you know how to speak
words it's that's all you need and so
I'm like what is this piece of paper
going to get me that I can't just say so
you know you know what I did you want
how easy it is I went to college for one
month at a community college and then I
checked off on every job application
some college they never asked for
diploma again no didn't need it no all
right let's let's read some more Daniel
Caldwell says Hey crew I'm Logistics
coordinator guy in Pittsburgh I've been
site manager for Seven Super Bowl
halftime shows and best boy for local
rigging crews in the Berg may I be of
assistance for your in your upcoming
visit I'd love to help the CH the answer
is yes but uh I don't do the
coordination for the uh uh Live Events
we have a live event coordinator and
then it's going to be like we're months
we a month maybe two months out from
like which venue it's going to be and
then which production company we're
going to use and so it's hard to just
take a Super Chat and be like we'd love
to have you because we don't even know
what we're doing and then it's like
what's likely going to happen is that
one guy will say here's the next guy and
the next guy says here's the next guy
and then it all like falls down like you
know dominoes all right we'll grab one
more one more Super Chat for some reason
super chats just aren't loading I don't
know why yeah I see that yep all right
Matt Kinder says today is my birthday I
watch timcast every single night I love
the show and I love what you're doing
for the culture keep up the good work
happy birthday Happ birer yeah happy
birthday Matt happy birthday happy
birthday Matt last one waffle Sensei
says Josh why should I vote for a
Libertarian when it will not result in a
Libertarian president it will help
Democrats win voting for Trump saves him
from false imprisonment and stands up
for the principles of Liberty itself I
love these questions these are my
favorite questions and they ask me every
single day first of all um I don't care
about your your candidate honest to God
I've lived through Reagan uh Bush
Clinton Trump Biden and my life has
never been enriched by by a president
not once not one time has they have they
ever made my life better they never made
my family's life better and like I said
earlier in the show every single piece
of bad legislation that's ever gotten
through the house and the executive
branch has had bipartisan support every
single time and I don't care I don't
care about your candidates anymore
truthfully but the the the other thing
too is like is like we your candidate it
doesn't deserve the votes they have to
earn the votes that's literally what
politics is and here's the best part
about this voting for a Libertarian
especially if you can waste your vote
because libertarian candidates not going
to win presidency in 2024 that's just
insane if somebody's telling you they
are they're they're a liar but yeah with
that attitude well crazier things have
happened I'm sure but um you know if you
were to get us that percentage that
makes us a national major political
party now you have another party
swimming around in the water that
actually makes your candidates have to
start uh governing the way that they
campaign and that's a really important
thing right is like we've been l to
repeatedly in these campaigns these high
dollar campaigns while they're stuff in
their pockets and doing all this bad
stuff and sending all your tax money
around all these different countries 200
countries every year right they never
govern the way that they campaign but if
you got the 40-year-old Blue Collar
working class guy that put this boots on
every morning now coming for your long
held position of power well you might
have to start doing the things you said
you were going to do and so it it's just
a challenge to the system man yeah Abol
comp if you believe in the free market
which I like to call the consumer-driven
Market you know that uh uh uh
competition breeds Innovation and breeds
success the argument is typically if
you're in a blue State and you know it's
going Democrat then you can help the
Libertarians get a higher percentage and
increase their competition or you can
always vote libertarian locally it's not
always just about President yeah there's
a lot of local candidates are really
good and and we win local C we win a lot
people think that we don't win any races
we win you know two at least 200 an
election cycle of Mayors and City
councils and all kinds of stuff so all
right everybody smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.net
you can find it at youtube.com backf the
death spots and of course the campaign
website's Joshua Smith 20124 you can
find all my info there donate to the
campaign become a volunteer all the good
things that we need and uh follow me on
Twitter Joshua atlarge that's awesome
it's been so fun having you here I'm
Hannah Clair brimo I'm a writer for
timcast.net and Instagram if you want to
follow me personally I'm on Instagram at
hanac clairy and I'm on Twitter at hcbo
guys thank you so much and of course
tonight is the night you're going to
subscribe to me on YouTube it happened
I'm fully monetized tomorrow is one of
my most exciting interviews I've ever
had it's at 3:30 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time with James T one of the leading
crafing scientists on on Earth at Rice
University they're doing flash Jewel
creation of graphine and hydrogen for
fuel this interview is going to be
incredible the guy's brilliant and I
want to see you there come join me at
3:30 p.m. Eastern Standard Time at Ian
Crossland on YouTube and I'll catch you
there and I am surge.com I enjoy today's
show pleasure seeing you I guess I guess
meeting you for the first time meeting
for the first time yeah I follow you on
Twitter man I'm a fan that's you said
anyways guys follow me on Twitter too
surge.com we'll see you all over at
timcast.net minute thanks for hanging
out